all right I have some new tour dates to
let you know about I'll be in Norfolk VA
Virginia on November 9. I'll be Roanoke
VA November 10 Huntington West Virginia
November 11th over there at the Mountain
Health Arena formerly known as The Big
Sandy I'll be in Evansville Indiana on
November 1 5 at the Ford Center and
Winston-Salem North Carolina November
17th as well as New Orleans Louisiana on
November 24th at the UNO Lakefront Arena
all tickets are available at theovan.com
t-o-u-r
[Music]
um we have been moving into some bigger
venues really grateful for it
um and we'll do a mix of bigger and
smaller ones at the time and
um just because we don't want to be on
tour forever you know we want to be on
tour for a while we just don't want to
be on
you know until
we're deceased or whatever so thank you
guys for your support theovan.com
t-o-u-r and if tickets are too high
price just wait we'll come back through
sometime gang
Dr John vervaki is a professor of
psychology at the University of Toronto
he currently teaches courses on thinking
and reasoning uh with a focus on
cognitive development intelligence
mindfulness and the psychology of wisdom
he is a smarter guy he's an information
man you know
he's also an expert in Buddhist
psychology he has a 50-part lecture
series on YouTube called Awakening from
the meaning crisis I've personally been
thinking a lot about meaning and what it
what just meaning of life meaning of
self
um things like that you know we had a
call about it on the last solo episode
and and uh and that's one of the things
that uh Dr vervecki is is um is highly
informed about so we're gonna spend some
time today with him and uh delve into
that and some other things I'm very
grateful uh that he's here today today's
guest is Dr John vervecki
[Music]
I sit and tell you my story
people and I will find a song
[Applause]
uh John viveki thank you so much for
being here it's great pleasure feeling
yeah it's really exciting man
um a lot of my friends have been uh
turned on to you and just like your
ability to like share your thoughts like
in a concise and and informative enough
way where I guess people are able to
absorb them and they don't sound too
monotonous where it sounds too much like
you're studying kind of yeah you know
well I mean I I really
uh well I'm
I really believe in I don't just believe
I really believe in the work I'm doing
it's it's like it's a calling for me
um and so
um and it's something that I live and I
I part I mean I've been a teacher for a
very long time and I think part of
being a good teacher is to always be
yourself learning and so I try to teach
by sharing the enthusiasm of the
learning I'm going through like even
when I'm doing a lecture I'll learn
something will come up and that moment
will Jazz me and that's that's the style
I've tried to develop and it seems to
work at least for the material I've been
privileged to get to teach yeah yeah
yeah and you teach all I guess I mean a
lot of people like I guess a lot of
things that I get shared for about yours
or like about meaning and looking into
meaning yes and especially at a time
where it feels like people are
or for me even if I mean it feels like
we're getting into this cul-de-sac in
America where it's like is there a lot
of value to my life do I am I just a cog
in the wheel am I just a consumer is
there any
you know what is the purpose for me I
think a lot of people are starting to
ask themselves that yeah yeah I call
that the meaning crisis and I think
there's good evidence that it's becoming
very prevalent in the west whatever that
means these days but you know sort of
North America Europe you know yeah uh
Japan Hawaii yeah Australia you know
things like that
um and the symptoms are that you can
sort of see symptoms of it
um all through the culture and
um and I've also seen a significant
increase
um in in the work I'm doing both
academically and in the public sphere uh
especially since covet covet really
ramped a lot of these issues up for
people in a powerful way
what the issues of like questioning
themselves what's going on yeah so the
thing the thing one of the interesting
things that uh kobit did is it threw
people back onto their inner life
um and what's interesting is our culture
especially North American culture
um right and I'm not the first to
observe it you know it has a high
preponderance of a tendency towards
narcissism being very like you know uh
so people have oriented their lives in a
very self-centered way but and but they
thought that right or they could maybe a
better way of putting it they confuse
that with having deep rich inner
resources and when everything sort of
stopped and they couldn't focus the
world on them and they had to focus on
themselves in order to find resources
and what you found was a bifurcation
like a division uh some people were like
whoa that like that really threw them
um so I I I'll I'll say something to you
and I I'm of two two minds of it because
I'm happy about it as a scientist could
I made a prediction and I'm sad about it
as a human being because it's not a good
prediction
um so just as the pandemic was hitting I
said what you're going to get is you're
going to get a rise in uh turn that
Julian Evans uh made famous called
conspirituality this mixture of
conspiracy theories and spirituality and
that took off and then I said as we come
out of the pandemic we'll get a mental
health Spike and then a little bit later
sort of an increase in crime and all of
these things are coming to pass because
what happened is many people are thrown
into the interior life only to realize
for all of the self-centeredness they've
actually not given any wise attention to
their inner life and they were suddenly
without resources other people saw this
as a an opportunity unity and they
framed it that way and so what's been
springing up where all of these online
communities where people
not to sound too highfalutin or anything
but people started to say I know I
really want to cultivate
wisdom I mean there's tons of
information there's a lot of
mixed up with it there's you know
there's all this stuff and there's
science and that but I want wisdom and
so and I get I've gotten involved with
quite a few of these communities so that
was that was there's there's both you
still have both negative and positive
symptoms in the culture uh like you know
um the number of close friends people
have is reliably declining even for all
of our social net internet connections
uh loneliness is becoming epidemic and
loneliness is like it's very unhealthy
we are we are we are naturally social
cultural beings and loneliness is what's
becoming a hobby too for some people in
a way it's becoming almost uh so common
that it's like um or not common but it's
well I guess common I guess and once you
start to become something you there's a
part of you that will want to find the
most organized way to be it and to
engage in it yeah so even in loneliness
it's almost becoming a culture you know
it is but it's a culture with great cost
um I mean we have weird things happening
like the UK has set up a Ministry of
loneliness which sounds like something
out of Orwell right like the ministry of
loneliness yeah and it's like well how
did we get there yeah it sounds like an
Ozzy Osbourne album oh yeah maybe yeah
yeah
I wonder how he would say that it makes
me lonely
he probably would get one of his kids I
don't even talk anymore but
um
but yeah well so so to go back so you're
looking at so when you look at like so
kovid you're saying head of uh was an
opportunity or caused a lot of us to
like
interflect yes look inside of ourselves
yes yes okay and some people did it like
in a healthy way yes where they kind of
looked inside of themselves and were
like wow I haven't looked in here in a
while I'm going to find ways to
challenge myself and see what's going on
here and I'm going to join other groups
and uh people that are curious about
um their inner self and then other p and
then what the other group what happened
well I mean they a lot of them sort of
fell into the things that were already
at work in the culture the meaning
crisis predates by like centuries
um but
um you know you saw a rise in mental
health issues so depression and anxiety
have gone up and they have continued to
increase and this is quite independent
of how affluent so Silicon Valley has a
tremendous problem with depression and
anxiety here are the people who are
supposed to be at the Pinnacle of our
society yeah we idolize them right and
yet they're they're they're their kids
are in trouble and they're in trouble in
certain ways have we always throughout
time have people always searched for
meaning in their life yeah it's always
been like um are we at like a
because we were like you're saying that
Kobe kind of put us in this place where
it kind of put us in a fast forward of
people willing to start to look at that
because the the fabric of society kind
of stopped and paused and so you're left
with yourself really yeah
um but people have always looked for
meaning that's exactly right I mean so
in the series I did and in the book on
on zombies the book is in the book is
the idea that zombies are a myth that
arose to try and give like give people
an image of the meaninglessness in their
lives
but we talked about two kinds of issues
one are what we call like perennial
problems like you said there's issues
that human beings always have confronted
and we can get into why that might be
the case
um and then there's also historical
factors that are now have been growing
since the late Middle Ages and
accelerating and things have you know
there's been a lot of major things uh
that are accelerants on those historical
forces and what happens is the
historical forces sort of undermine the
like the like you said the cultural
fabric that normally helps people to
address the perennial problems and then
what happens is you get a vicious cycle
The Perennial problems get worse the
social fabric tears more The Perennial
problems get and you start to spiral and
that's where it feels like kind of like
we're at yes yes that's that's and and
that's that's amazing so when when I I
didn't I didn't like how did The
Awakening from the meaning crisis came
up was actually a former student of mine
took a class with me and said you should
turn this into a YouTube series in The
Awakening for the meaning crisis is your
YouTube series right yeah I have two
major YouTube series I have Awakening
from the meaning crisis which is about
what we're talking about and then
there's after Socrates which is an
attempt to do an in-depth
um
reconstruction
um reverse engineering of a Socratic way
of life
um as a way of cultivating wisdom both
individually and collectively what does
that mean a Socratic way of life we're
not going to know what that means right
so the unexamined life is worth living
since this is a Socratic quote he says
this on at his trial uh and they
basically say to him uh stop doing
philosophy we'll let you go and he said
or or if not we'll kill you right oh wow
and he says uh well the unexamined life
is not worth living I'd rather I'd
rather die and so
Socrates Socrates is very very
interesting he has he has two sort of
influences
one influence he's influenced by the
sort of the first scientists that are
emerging in ancient Greece he takes a
look at the Natural Science and it's a
it's a breakthrough like as opposed to a
mythological way of thinking these early
thinkers are using observation and
reason to try and understand the world
he thinks that's powerful but he finds
that the science and this is relevant
for us right he finds that the
scientific information isn't
existentially relevant it doesn't lead
to personal transformation it doesn't
have how to become a better person so it
gives him a lot of information and it
makes him understand things but it's not
helping him as a person as a in his soul
and you see and that's what how a lot of
people feel about our scientific world
view we have a scientific world of view
that explains everything except how we
generate science and how we have live it
live how we should live meaningful lives
within that worldview so Socrates says
that's not good enough the truth seeking
is good but it's it's not giving me any
relevance and then there's the sofas and
that that literally means sort of the
Wise Guys and these are the people that
invent rhetoric you know the first sort
of
um
first good use of in in a
technical sense in Harry Frankfurt sense
you know the liar tries to manipulate
you because you care about the truth and
they try to convince you that something
is truth but the artist does
something different they try to get you
unconcerned about whether or not
something is the truth and just caught
up in how catchy it is advertising all
advertising works this way you know you
what you you watch the alcohol
commercial right here's a bar and
somebody gets a drink and there's
gorgeous people and happy music and
everybody's well-dressed and smiling go
into a bar right that's not that's not
and we all know it's false it's not the
same in there no but
catchy
it triggers all kind you know sexuality
and vibrancy and sociality yeah
possibility yeah and all that and it's
so it gets very catchy and you don't
care about the truth and you get caught
up on how catchy it is and this is and
this is what the sophists discovered
they had they knew they they learned how
to make things catchy so they would
really go deep into people and change
them now they did it in a manipulative
fashion now Socrates said well they're
the opposite they're giving me lots of
relevance transformative power but no
truth and what he did is basically said
I want the two together I want
transformative truths I want to I want
to go on a quest
find those truths that catch wow he was
like a gangster huh yeah he was well
he's a hero to me yeah well it sounds I
guess what I'm saying it sounds like he
was like a John Wayne of like let's do
we're gonna do this a new way and this
is the way that it needs to be it just
sounds like he was a real Pioneer kind
of he is I mean it's called the socratic
Revolution I mean he's an astonishing
individual uh like he he was extremely
Brave he had a reputation like he was a
soldier
um and at several times in battle he
showed tremendous courage and presence
of mind when everybody else is panicking
wow he could he could stand in one
place like in like in profound
meditation for like 24 48 Hours
uh he uh he was he was his life was
threatened several times and he never
sort of capitulated to uh to the forces
um he's Brave he's Brave
um
he I mean he creative it sounds like
yeah and he's TR and he he invented this
way of interacting with people
um he would ask them questions and he
would try try and draw out
um like he compared himself to a midwife
I help I help people to give birth to
themselves wow and so he he wasn't he
wasn't like he would often show people
that
their their claims to being wise or to
knowledge didn't work he would get them
into this state people said it was like
being stung by uh like by a Stingray or
a spell cast on you you'd get into this
state and he did this for a particular
reason so the the Athenians had oracles
like the Oracle at Delphi have you ever
been to Delphi I know uh I don't think
so I have is it
um nope I haven't it puts the zap on you
man yeah yeah like it like you stand in
front of the omphalus the navel of the
world and this this Chasm drops away and
then this in front of you and this
mountain goes up and you know and this
woman she would sit in a cave and
there's some speculation that she was
getting intoxicated and then she would
she would speak answer people's
questions now when you're an oracle
right if you want to stay in business as
an oracle you don't give really clear
answers to people like right right
because you need them to come back you
need him to come back so you know you
know should I marry Cassandra well
sometimes the squirrels don't gather
nuts yeah okay so there was so a friend
of Socrates went
to the Oracle and I I always I have no
basis for saying that but I always
picture them sort of like sort of
smirking and nudging each other we're
going to ask you this really cool
question right yeah yeah and so she goes
up and they go up in the and they and
they they say to her is is there anyone
wiser than Socrates and they're
expecting this really cryptic and and
she said no no human being is wiser than
Socrates straight answer wow
so that she went back so he went back
and they tell Socrates no you and I were
honest if they said we got that message
from the gods we go yeah yeah I always
knew it right I always know he does he
does this other thing and this tells you
how Socratic he is he says
well the gods can't lie this but by the
way that's one way and he's
revolutionary the gods aren't like the
ancient gods just superheroes the gods
are like moral exemplars for Socrates so
they can't lie but he also says but I
know I'm not wise how can those both be
true and he turns it into this Quest so
he goes and he keeps asking people right
so somebody claims to know something or
they they know what a particular virtue
is they know what courage is and he'll
ask like two generals and they'll and
they'll and he'll he'll constantly
question them and it's and he's trying
to draw it out and he's trying to find
out
and what typically happens is the the
this what's called a dialogue Plato it
ends with no clear answer no clear
definition but Socrates isn't a skeptic
so the the the uh so so he so he doesn't
get a clear answer but that's okay the
goal isn't is the goal to get a clear
answer just to create conversation
beyond that see the goal is to get
people to take up his quest ah see so if
you look at so he's talking to these two
generals and the two generals about
courage one of them does the I just know
he just speaks from his intuition and
Socrates destroys that shows him with
the contradictions the problem the other
quotes So the first person speaks more
like a first person perspective well I
just know
and Socrates destroys that and the other
person you know speaks from this third
person wealth here's a technical
definition I got from the sofas and blah
blah blah blah yeah yeah and and
Socrates destroys that and then there's
and Socrates can't offer definition
and you think what was this all for but
you have to see in a dialogue you have
to pay attention to the drama not just
the argument
because what the two generals say is we
want our sons to come and spend time
with you and live with you Socrates
because our sons are going to get
courage from you so actually these can't
explain you can't define courage courage
courage if you think you can put courage
into a definition you don't get it
right you have to get into this not the
first person this or the third person
this second person you us together right
you catch it but it has but it's it's
just caught truth remember we were
talking about and what happens is
Socrates exemplifies uh what it is and
he he lives it in conversation with
people so that they start to catch that
orientation and catch his quest wow and
was that a new thing at the time to have
that sort of energy to have that like
for people to really start to question
things like that so as far as we can
tell in this way it's called a Socratic
Revolution and there doesn't seem to be
any of the ancient sources that
contradict this Socrates and Socrates
invents discovers we don't have to
there's a Latin word that's much better
inventil it means to discover or or
invent right he he inventios right this
way of helping people to give birth to
themselves so so the people I work with
we've Crea we've tried to reverse
engineer this practice we call it
dialectic into D logos we have workshops
that sort of get people to take this up
and and so
what we do is we'll have them do these
practices around a virtue like courage
more honesty authenticity
and it's and we and and what happens is
they they and we tell them this but they
also realize it right because you're not
the point isn't to be right about this
the point is to come into right
relationship with the virtue and that's
what happens when they do these practice
people come out and go I'm kind of
experiencing something like ah and a
love for Oh I thought I always knew what
honesty was like the technical
definition or the intuition like the two
generals but but now I I don't but I
like I'm like Socrates so you get this
right orientation and now we go back to
Socrates because he finally resolved
that Paradox that he had from the gods
he realized that he was wise in that he
knew when he did not know something but
not in the shallow sense that I you know
I don't know about Albanian tin
production or something like that right
but in this sense we're talking about
was it which is like I really don't know
what honesty is I have a I have a love
for it and I'm oriented I want to be in
the right relationship I want to open
myself up I want to learn more about it
um
football is back in full swing with
another week of epic games
and who's got you covered on the action
every single one of them DraftKings
sports book and official sports betting
partner of the NFL new customers can bet
five dollars on football and get two
hundred dollars instantly in bonus bets
nobody's missing out on the action this
season all DraftKings customers can take
advantage of two new offers every game
day this September get in on the NFL
week two action with DraftKings sports
book download the app now and use code
Theo to sign up new customers can bet
just five dollars and take home 200
instantly in bonus bets only on
draftking Sportsbook with code Theo the
crown is yours you got to keep that hair
baby you got to maintain that fleece
that's important that's right and keeps
can help you do it you shouldn't do it
alone no
keeps is an online subscription service
that makes it easy and more more
affordable for men to treat their male
pattern baldness from the comfort of
their home
with keeps you can get clinically proven
treatments to address hair loss and
boost hair regrowth delivered right to
your door in discreet packaging hmm
what's he getting I don't know
keeps offers both of the FDA approved
hair loss treatment options as well as a
two-in-one gel that combines both
treatments hair loss stops with keeps
for a special offer to get started go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo or click in the
link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash t-h-e-o
when it comes to like searching for like
meaning right like as a person you know
do we do it is it something that we do
as individuals like are we do is there
any value in finding meaning as an
individual it feels like to me sometimes
more like the value is finding meaning
as like a species or like a group right
like I guess when I think about meaning
I don't think like
what is my what is the meaning for me
what is the purpose of my life I I find
my brain often thinks more like what is
our purpose right what is our meaning
um so the the individual poll is you
need to cultivate wisdom
but what's the collective pull and you
put your finger on it so what is this
meaning thing
so a lot if you do research on it
there's four dimensions to it uh and the
one that people think it's synonymous
with is having a purpose that's only one
of the dimensions it's actually not the
most important one of the dimensions of
meaning yeah meaning in life so we're
not talking about like the meaning of a
sentence we're talking about
what makes your life worth living even
though it has all the frustrations and
failures and faults and flaws in it
right because I think especially you get
to like a middle of your life kind of or
ballpark you know and you start that
really starts to hit home you're like oh
well my youth is disappearing yeah what
is the what is my purpose here and then
is it the purpose of just me or am I
part of a group and we have a purpose
those are the questions yeah that I've
really kind of right see us getting hit
with a lot so purpose is important but
there's other factors uh one was it was
in the literature was called coherence
but some of the original experiments
have failed to replicate and so it's a
broader notion it's more like your world
has to make sense to you it can't be
absurd right because if the world
becomes absurd then then you start to
really feel that reality is meaningless
well that's starting that's another
thing that's starting to happen I mean
we can go into that yeah we can we can
and that's very different people can
people can act on purpose uh even within
an absurd World well a lot out of my
meaning I've noticed like recently like
it seemed like um
recently it seemed a lot like uh the the
texture or the fabric of society is kind
of eroding in America right like a lot
of traditions are being yeah yeah said
that they're no good we're like
um trying to renegotiate our past to
make it look a certain way
um everything's in question yeah a lot
of things are in question a lot of
traditi people are saying that even like
the Pledge of Allegiance for just things
that gave us all commonality seem to be
um disappearing right yeah and so I
realized that that started to hurt me
because I was like man a lot of my
meaning as a person I had attached to
excellent a lot of these commonalities
and I didn't realize that until they
started to go away I'm like well if this
stuff doesn't mean anything like then do
I mean anything okay so notice that
notice that so there's two that's the
two missing Dimensions one is people
right
and one is they they their their reality
can't be flat it has to have a depth
they have to they have to be able to
point to something to say this is really
real
right if you like if everything feels
sort of illusory then you're also in a
kind of a nightmare situation right but
the one you just pointed to this is the
crucial one and this is the one and I'm
going to pun a little bit here this is
the one that matters it's called
mattering this is the one that matters
the most and mattering is this
you there's a really good book by Susan
Wolf called meaning in life and why it
matters
um and you know when you what the
metaphor people use is I want to feel
connected to something larger than
myself something bigger than myself
and here's a way of seeing if you have
this in your life and why it might have
come into question like you were just
talking about ask yourself what do you
want to exist even if you don't
and how much of a difference do you make
to it now
okay so take me through an example of
that so let me think what do I want to
exist even if you don't even if I don't
exist yeah
um
probably families yeah so these are
people you want them to exist even if
you don't yeah yeah and Happy children
yeah happy families maybe would be
something I would say and do you think
you make much of a difference to them
right now
not a ton right so you need a good
answer for both of those to have a
strong sense of meaning in life
okay so take me through an example of
somebody that would have a good Aunt
like that what would be an answer that
would probably leave somebody feeling
fulfilled after they asked themselves
those questions well I want to I want to
point to something that you put your
finger on uh there's a decline in the
bigger picture world view
um and it off the World Views that we we
experience them and I'm trying to use
this term very broadly religiously so I
don't mean just like Christianity or
Judaism or something like that but I
also mean what used to be called
American Civil religion like you have
their Heroes and things are sacred like
the flag and you pledge allegiance which
is a kind of prayer right and so and
both of those religious Frameworks and
even though they're tearing each other
apart about it right now they're falling
right and so people used to say
they would die for their country people
did it in World War II they right they
want the US the United States to
continue existing they think the
universe is a better place if the US is
in it and they are making a difference
they're in like they're in Germany and
they're liberating the world from
tyranny and so they're making a real
difference right to this overarching
worldview American democracy americanism
they had meaningless so much meaning in
life that like Socrates they're willing
to die for it and they must have I mean
to think like yes I mean I mean they had
people that were CH lying to get into
the draft yes like I want to go serve my
country I will die from my country they
believe that much in it it feels like
we're
further from that now for sure so that
the idea of your country being that
thing is probably less right so that's
the other poll now remember we talked
about the individual poll then there's
the world view the the right the the
poll that we no one you didn't invent
English did I right it's these are the
things we invent together and we evolve
together and we participate in together
and one is like there was a great
metaphor but an academic called Peter
Berger he called it the sacred canopy
where you had this world view that
basically gave you uh it told you how to
be an agent in the world and it it made
the world a meaningful Arena so there
was an agent Arena relationship and they
were attuned to each other so you knew
what to do you knew how to fit in and
and so you had this world view that
rounded things and this is the bigger
picture and then people could could
connect
their personal
wisdom cultivation to this bigger thing
and enhance their meaning in life and
this is what religions both civil and
you know uh religious sorry we don't
have we need another sacred I suppose
civil and sacred religions they were
both doing for people and these have
been breaking down right for a whole so
those are the historical factors and
when they break down people's ability to
find purpose and depth and Clarity and
mattering gets undermined and there's
self-deception exacerbates because they
get isolated like we were talking about
in covet they get disconnected from a
shared worldview that gives them these
these ecologies of practices you can't
do them on your own right you'll fall
prey to sort of you know if you're just
an autodidactic like a self-learner
you'll fall prey to all your biases and
all your egocentrisms and your
unrealized comfort zones you need other
people to be so we need each other to
have meaning yeah we transcend each
other through each other
this is Socrates you know how I can most
transcend myself and overcome my bias
and my narrow frame is you challenging
you me yeah we are the keys to each
other's locks yes yes yes yes and so
what happened is right you need that
world view to home those ecologies of
practice right give them legitimacy give
them tradition right which is not the
same thing as Nostalgia and then what
we've done is we've undermined that
world view we've we've torn apart the
ecologies of practices because and
people are are like they've largely
abandoned the Legacy religions they're
now abandoned abandoned abandoning the
Civil religions even the the very weak
religion of popular culture is breaking
down oh there's more fortnite players
and there are Protestants probably right
right yes you know but but look at how
look at how those like a symptom of the
meaning crisis is an attempt to create
World Views that have a myth when I say
mythological I don't mean that
negatively I don't mean like a lie I
mean myths aren't ancient stories about
the past they're they're they're they're
they're stories about perennial problems
and patterns right and so like think
about the whole MC universe and we call
it a universe we're trying to create
this entire world view in which
basically we have Bronze Age Gods who
nevertheless are Socratic Heroes and
pursue virtue and they're they fly
around and do all this stuff and it's
falling apart we can't even keep that
running yeah right like this is how bad
things are and so the perennial problems
start they start to get worse they tear
out what's left of the world view the
worldview can't home the ecology people
get more foolish more self and the whole
thing just Spirals and so if that was
that a good answer by the way to the two
polls yeah I think it was really good
man yeah I think it was really good I'm
you know I'm doing I'm doing a decent
job I think of keeping up good um I'm
trying to make it accessible for
listeners at the same time I think
you're doing a great job at that thank
you oh thanks man yeah I appreciate it
um so what happens historically in a
time where we get to a place like this
is there Pat has this happened before in
time yeah okay so we don't need to be
alarmed at the point like humans have
never been through this that's right
we've been through it before uh now
there's a like there's two there's two
uh stances on this that are both sort of
wrong because they're extreme one is oh
this is human beings have always said
the meanings improv and it's a
dismissive thing and then the other one
is no this is completely absolutely
unique and there's truth to both what's
unique is we Face a set of problems that
are Global in a way that was never
Global problems that were this like this
you know complex and and growing like we
Face an interconnection of the Advent of
you know AGI we already we're already
facing you know growing the growing
impact of social media you know people
are looking at issues around the
environment uh energy as you said our
political economic system is breaking
down is gridlocking and people are
losing faith in it and I use that word
deliberately in in in a deep way and so
those are those are I think unique
things we're facing and they
I think when we're in a meeting crisis
it's sort of
hamstrings us it really weakens our
ability to turn our best wisdom towards
these problems because when we're in a
meaning crisis right so oh especially
enough we're all isolated and we're
isolated and we're not our best it's
very self-motivated it's not our like
group conscience
um or we're acting out of fear a lot of
people yeah and we're acting out of like
and our ability to cut through the
and to realize when we're in
self-deception is you know being
seriously challenged oh yeah so our
ability to handle this is is very weak
but it is also the case that there have
been other points in time in which there
have been not globally but
um like in the ancient West at the
Hellenistic period there was a a meaning
crisis at that time too what was that
about
uh so it's basically so there's
Alexander the Great so Socrates was he
great or not well it depends so
um because that's a straight I mean
that's like you're not even leaving any
you know you're saying hey
so he he changes the course of the
history of Western civilization in a
profound way and if that's what you mean
by great just sort of changing the
course of things he's great okay I'll
give it to him then well but but I I
also want to say right that so my
partner like she's Persian and the
Alexander grade is the bad guy in the
Persian world right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so he's like uh
right but what he does is like he he
conquers most of you know the Silk Road
uh and you know uh the the some of the
major civilizations in Asia Europe and
Africa and then he dies at a young age
um and so his Empire breaks up into his
gen first of all there's a period of
fighting and and and and and then and
then and the generals carve up his
Empire and then there's just ongoing
Warfare now I just want to compare two
people somebody living at the time just
before Alexander the time of Aristotle
who taught Alexander by the way right
this is their life they live in a like a
polis a city they've lived there and
their ancestors have lived there for all
their life everybody around them speaks
the same language everybody practices
the same religion if you're in Athens
you participate well if you're a male so
it's you participate directly in the
government right you know you you know
about in person the leaders so right
this is like
after Alexander you're now in a world in
which the people you might have been
uprooted people have been uprooted moved
it was a little more Global than at that
point kind of exactly but that's exactly
the parallel right right so people
around you speak a different language
they haven't been there for years you
might not have your answers might not
have been there they have different
religions right you've conquered there's
an area that's been conquered so now
there's more of you that can consider
whenever you're making laws and rules
and these kingdoms are constantly
shifting so you may go to sleep in the
ptolemaic Empire and wake up in the
seleucid Empire and you don't know and
that's the thing the government is
thousands of kilometers away from you so
people felt um there's a term for this
it's called domicide which is the
killing of home they felt they didn't
feel at home in the world anymore so
this has been called an Age of Anxiety
and that what happened at that time and
in some ways this is the project I'm
trying to do now what happened at the
time is philosophy changed in order to
address
in order to address this meaning crisis
so before with Socrates and Plato you
already have these questions about
meaning and wisdom but what gets added
to this existential ethical Dimension is
what you might call a therapeutic
Dimension epicurus who's one of the
prototypical philosophers from this time
said call no man a philosopher who has
not alleviated the suffering of others
the philosopher became the physician of
the soul and what happened is philosophy
took on this dimension of how to
alleviate anxiety how to increase
people's sense of meaning and
connectedness and we got epicureanism
and stoicism and then eventually we got
neoplatonism that Drew them all together
and we got and you also had the the
emergence of new religions that we're
trying to right there was syncretic
religions which people were merging Gods
like or or mother goddesses because when
you don't have a home a mother goddess
becomes a really big thing Isis becomes
a big deal and of course Christianity
emerges in this mix too wow so that's
interesting because it's kind of where
we are I see that where we've been now
for a little bit like people are uh
gathering around
speakers or men and women who are able
to share a message of Hope or give them
um
make them feel like they have meaning or
purpose why people listen to or have
started to listen to people like um I
mean Jordan Peterson's an easy one
because he's been very popular guys like
you who are able to converse uh or just
you're able to put into words what a lot
of people can't that's one of the
problems that a lot of us have we can't
put certain things into words so we
start to
especially in times like this you start
to look to somebody who seems to have it
together
I think yeah does that make any sense or
no it does and it lands it lands very
well but it lands with a sort of a a a a
a very strong sense of responsibility
um that's true maybe it's putting too
much responsibility on those people I
guess I'm not looking at it from that
perspective I'm looking at it more from
like
the people in the in the polis in the
city or whatever who were like what do
we do now and and you know and like um
like as other things start to fall as
the fabric of our society the traditions
and stuff start to like get more opaque
or whatever does opaque let me know
opaque like like yeah okay see him as
well yeah yeah what do we do you know
and so you go to somebody who I think
sounds like they know what they're doing
right so it's again there's there's a
risk there right like there's a
tremendous risk of and there's risk both
ways there's a risk of the person the
figure uh being wrong well being wrong
or or not caring if they're wrong
there's a lot of right and
um and then and then there's also risk
for the person they might be sincere but
uh you know for every myth we have in
the Greek tradition of the hero we have
an equal myth of hubris hubris is when
you try to be the Gods and the guy like
Icarus you try to fly to the sun and the
right you try to or Fate on you try to
steer The Chariot of the Sun and you
right and Zeus has to kill you right all
that right humility basically right
right and Socratic humility right
um yeah I mean one way of understanding
the human task is to keep a keep a hold
on both the fact that we're finite we're
prone to error or self-deception and and
unforeseen fate but we're not just
animals we're also called to Virtue we
have a capacity to transcend we have to
hold the finitude of the Transcendence
together we just did the Transcendence
we we can fall prey to thinking we're
gods and then the hubris Falls and
that's what a lot of these thought
leaders do and then on the other hand
but if we don't give people something
they can just they can just collapse
into their finitude and and then their
their subject to tyranny and servitude
and despair and Plato is all about
trying and he uses Socrates to represent
somebody who Socrates described himself
as mataksu but Queen he was always
holding those two together and so I try
my I try to
take on the responsibility you've put
your finger on in and I try to live it
that way
um and and so I mean one of the things
people say to me
um and it's really a profound compliment
for me they'll a lot of people say
John you gave me the vocabulary like you
were talking about a few minutes ago to
talk about this to think about it to
talk to other people about it
um but I have to balance that off
with a tendency to get too self-absorbed
yeah in my own terminology and that's
the fallacy it's one of the I get I
don't know if the fallacy is a word but
not weiner I'm talking about the other
thing the
which one the
like a like a confusion fallacy and I'm
talking about yeah yes okay
um
yeah that's one of the fallacies of just
being human it's like you can
if you if when things start to go well
this happened to me before in my life I
started to get some popularity and yeah
things seemed like they were going good
and I started there was a moment where I
was like well I started asking myself
does God have some special plan for me
you know yeah yeah which is a dangerous
thing to start asking yourself it's okay
to ask to be curious and see if you know
what the how I can be of service but
part of that gets real tricky because
then you start thinking you have some
special power and that's where it can
just get scary and I think there's it's
just being human it's part of the it's
you know it's that's what that fulcrum
is right there is just trying to keep
that even you know until I think about
this daily I think about this daily I I
have a I have an amazing team of people
around me I have a non-for-profit
organization the ravaki foundation that
keeps the money and the power at an
arm's length to me I'm not I'm not in
charge of it uh uh I have a bunch of
people around me who have been given
ongoing non-negotiable permission to
tell me if I'm starting to believe my
own
um hey you don't strike me as that
person at all well um I wasn't trying to
say that no no no no I'm just trying to
examine this it's really interesting I
examine it for myself sometimes because
I have people that like will say hey man
you really helped me with this or you've
helped me like that's good think about
those things right it makes me feel like
I'm being of service right yeah but then
it's okay I have to be careful like that
I don't let that leave the room with me
yeah in a in it's like beautiful music
right yeah you you you you
joy in it while it's happening it
because somebody is sharing with you
right right and you don't want you don't
want to rain on somebody when they're
sharing with you because they need that
but then but it's like music when the
song's done the song's done don't keep
him yourself as you leave right yeah
John is great John is great yeah yeah
yeah exactly
today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp indeed better help they can
help they'll do it they help me
I tried them out I needed help I called
them
and I've gotten help that's it you can
do it over your phone it's easiest
discreet you can do it on FaceTime
especially if you live in an area in a
place where you're just you don't you
know if you go see the therapist they're
going to tell everybody now you're gonna
they gonna every time you go down to uh
the 7-Eleven or the Casey's they're
gonna know when you walk in oh that's
him he needs help
you can prevent all that if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get messed with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge
there's no shame in that game baby take
care of your brain and your heart
get a break from your thoughts with
better help visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Theo this episode is
sponsored by better help I want to let
you know that Morgan and Morgan has
teamed up with Richard Childress Racing
to support Kyle Busch and Austin Dillon
and are offering one lucky this past
weekend listener the opportunity to
attend race day in Las Vegas on October
1 5 that's right
they are giving one lucky winner two
thousand dollars and two tickets to see
Kyle Busch race live in Las Vegas this
October entering to win is easy just go
to
morganvegas.com this past weekend that's
Morgan
vegas.com slash this past weekend no
purchase necessary open a legal
residence of the 48 contiguous United
States and DC who are 18 and over
sweepstakes ends 10-1 2023 for entry and
official rules visit
morganvegas.sweepp.com also if you're
ever injured you can check out Morgan
and Morgan their fee is free unless they
win
for more information go to
forthepeople.com
this past weekend or dial pound law
pound 529 from your cell phone that's
f-o-r the people.com this past weekend
or pound law from your cell this is a
paid advertisement and we are grateful
to Morgan and Morgan it's the calm right
now before the holiday storm and I hate
to say it that the holidays are coming
but you can hear them you can hear them
holidays are coming they're humming
around the bend
you know that but you can prepare your
e-commerce business for the holiday rush
now
just by using ship station oh God it
sounds good
whether you're shipping from your house
or a warehouse
ship station can help increase your
profitability
save time automating your shipping and
returns in the ship station dashboard
and keep costs down with
industry-leading carrier discounts while
your holiday orders roll in so set your
business up for Success this holiday
season with ship station
simply go to shipstation.com and use
code Theo today and sign up for your
free 60-day trial that's two months
that's shipstation.com
code Theo so one thing that I think
about when I think about meaning is like
if you look at like some past cultures
they had
um
they would give their when people were
dying they would give them like weapons
to go in the afterlife yes like
medallions maybe a couple you know
chocolates or freaking I don't know if
they have butterscotchers or whatever
back then but a couple little candies
for the road you know they would put
that in their bear in their casket right
yeah so imagine what life was like when
you thought that yes death like there
was a whole no like you this was just a
preparation yes that must have added so
much I feel like that would have added
so much meaning it can to being alive
whereas now that doesn't seem yeah it's
not as prevalent I mean nobody's I don't
you know I was at a place one time
somebody maybe put a couple Quaaludes or
something in a dude's pocket in a casket
but I've never been there with her you
know armoring them up and putting them
in like you know
um Under Armor or anything you know so
that's a really important thing there's
a really
great great book I'm teaching an online
course for the healthy income Academy on
Beyond nationalism and we started it
with tillex book the courage to be which
is a really great book the courage to be
by tilak you said Paul tillich yeah okay
and he talks about these diff these
things that can really take people in
the despair
um and he talks about them analytically
but he's very aware that they can
interpenetrate and you can have multiple
ones at the same time and one is the one
you just mentioned
um it's mortality
um but you have to you have to broaden
it you have to understand mortality
think about we have the we talk about a
fatality but that the base of that is
not death the base word in there is fate
this is the idea your death is just an
example of how the universe is
perpetually profoundly beyond your
control you can have met the woman of
your life and you both know it and
you're gonna have and you step into
traffic and the truck hits you and it
right and it's not the case like in a
romantic comedy yeah that the great
narrative that is unfolding like me Joe
Black that's what happened I think in
that yes so we we we we we confront
we confront fatality which It ultimately
in our mortality
um that's one one is one we've been
talking about meaninglessness the world
can just suddenly seem flat and futile
and we can feel alienated and anxious
and then the other one is
guilt not just in the everyday sense of
like oh you know I shouldn't have said
that to Peter it's in a more profound
sense of
I think I'm just a bad person right I
just I like and not necessarily evil I
just you the weight of your flaws and
your failings and your faults can be
magnified especially if you if you're
very honest I mean Theo I don't want to
live forever because I don't want to try
and carry that Boulder that will get
larger and larger of my flaws and my
Fates I'm my finitude right and that can
weigh you down and so I think
I think one of the things that I think
you're right one of the things that most
people have lost although not as many as
you might think so although
uh participation in the Legacy religions
the world religions is declining even in
America now America was always the weird
exception but now it's starting to
decline so in a couple Generations most
people in America won't be religious
adherents Wow that's scary feeling well
that's domicide so welcome to it sorry
that's the domicide the loss of Home
loss of home oh the loss of feeling home
loss of loss of feeling at home in the
universe right we used to call it a
cosmos Cosmos was like cosmetic
beautiful and now we call it Universe
right it's flat uh we don't there's no
depth to it so those all three of those
intersect now one of the things and I
want to go back to remember I mentioned
like the Hellenistic philosophers like
epicurus even Socrates they tried to
address the problem
Socrates said all the philosophy is a
preparation for death right
um and they tried to address it in a
different way
it it
could I try just just to give people
first of all one thing other cultures so
I have a lot I've been practicing within
taoism and Buddhist practices also for
three decades so uh see so if you look
in even in vedanta if you're looking
within Hinduism at least important I
mean I don't want to talk about the
homogeneous but at least large swaths of
Hinduism Buddhism right immortality is a
curse
like immortality living forever is a
curse they all viewed it like that
you're saying yes okay because the idea
is reincarnation you come back again and
again and again and again and like I
said the like this is kind of like Karma
the the the the the faults and the flaws
and the failings pile up
and right and and it just and it becomes
uh it becomes just horrible
um and what you seek for is Moksha you
seek for Liberation from rebirth or
reincarnation or you seek Nirvana you're
seeking you I don't want to be reborn oh
so when there's real in some of those
religions where there's reincarnation
they seek to be freed from that that is
the core of vedanta you want to you want
to realize Moksha by realizing that the
ground of your being your soul and the
ground of reality are one and that
liberates you from being attached to I
want this I want this to survive I want
this to survive and let go of that and
Buddhism has something similar it tries
to convince you that the idea that you
have a substantial Soul Atman is an ALT
is ultimately false and if you can
really truly not just as an idea but
like we were talking about earlier if
you can let go of it all the way through
then you'll be liberated from that so
it's a different response now the
Hellenistic philosophers did did
something very similar in the west
epicurus he was famous for this he he
didn't try and convince people that they
were Immortal he's he he he tried to get
people to change the way they frame
their mortality
so he famously said where death is I am
not where I am death is not what he's
trying what do you what what's he's
doing there is he playing games what
he's saying is you can't actually
experience being dead because if you're
dead you're not there there's no
experience and as long as you're
experiencing you're not dead you can
never have the experience of being dead
and so so what do you know and people
say that's not good enough that's not
the point the point is so he's trying to
get you to be more Discerning what is it
you are afraid of you're afraid of dying
you're afraid of going through the
process of losing your Vitality losing
your relationships losing your body
you're not afraid of death you're afraid
like you're not afraid of all the time
before your birth when you didn't didn't
exist right right so right so what is it
you're afraid of diet you're afraid of
living losing so here's what we do find
the things
that you can keep up until the very last
moment of Consciousness and he said the
one thing the two things that you can
always have
our wisdom and friendship cultivate wise
friendships and friendships that support
wisdom and he was he was suffering
horrible illness as he was dying and he
took that right through and he right and
he also taught people how to not fear
the gods right and and and and and so
that was one response the stoics you
know Marcus Aurelius people all know
Marcus Aurelius from the movies right
and Marcus really it's the what the
stoic said is look the problem we are is
what what we set our hearts on what we
what we identify with right like we're
always assuming and assigning identities
for example right now I'm assuming the
identity of like you know this academic
person I'm assigning an identity to you
but this isn't the identity I would have
with my partner when I go home at night
that would be weird right and I wouldn't
assign the whoa sorry are you going to
interview me now right right that's
weird right and so we're always assuming
and assigning identities and we're doing
this in this interlocking manner that
agent Arena but here's the thing most of
the time we do this unconsciously we do
it mindlessly yeah automatically
reactively and so we set our we identify
with the wrong things and so what the
stock said is I'm going to use I'm gonna
I know your viewers can't see I'm
drawing a horizontal line we identify
with horizontal things we identify with
trying to extend our life have more Fame
have more power and they said that's
ultimately doomed you're pitting
yourself against the universe you're
very the universe is going to crush you
yeah
instead go vertical Seneca said even
when you're painted into a corner you
can jump into the sky hmm so the
vertical is don't try and get the most
extension of your life try and get the
greatest depth there's a there's a book
wow that's so pal that's really really
cool yeah and so you live that and you
try and realize that now they did this
and uh even when you're painting a
corner you can jump into the sky yeah
and so things people can do when they
feel like they're painted into a corner
they can help somebody else that will
that creates probably some and they can
get more in touch they can and this is
helping other people service is
definitely a way to do this you where
they can get think about they think
about this as the I mentioned earlier
people don't want a flat world they want
a world with depth and height to it and
you can you can you can touch the depths
of reality and the heights of reality
and you know of course you can do this
with mindfulness practices and other
kinds of practices and this thing is I
get a lot of questions people ask me
like hey man I'm in a tough spot right
now I feel like there's no way out what
do I do right now so that's why and a
lot of times I'll say to the people
people you know try and be of service
try and help someone else get out of
yourself you know we get we get trapped
in in ourselves definitely that's that's
very that's very much the case so that's
what I'm thinking what other things
would you recommend you think well so
let's talk about this let's let's talk
about and
um
I think this will have personal
relevance to you too and and if uh I
don't want to push any buttons
inappropriately uh but uh let's talk
about when people the one of the worst
versions of that which is addiction okay
and so my friend and colleague Mark
Lewis has one of the best theories of
addiction it's basically a reciprocal
narrowing Theory so so your world is
like getting really problematic so you
take a substance to
alter your State of Consciousness so
that it doesn't seem to be so
threatening at least for a bit the
problem you pay for that is you weaken
your cognitive abilities now when you
come when you when you weaken your
cognitive abilities your ability to
solve problems in the world goes down so
now the world's more threatening so now
you've got to take the substance and now
you got to take more of it and then you
weaken your cognitive abilities more and
you see what's happening the world is
getting more and more oppressive fewer
and fewer options and there's you have
less and less cognitive flexibility you
left have less and less ability to move
maneuver in your mind to change until
you can't be any different and the world
has no future and that's addiction
you've reciprocally narrowed your way
all the way yourself all the way down
now I was having dinner with Mark lunch
with Mark Lewis and I said to him and
Plato's in the back of my mind because I
got this from Plato I said to mark I
said
well if you can reciprocally narrow
can't you reciprocally open
can't you
bring some flexibility to your mind and
that opens up the world you start to see
the world in more depth and then that
actually opens you up into the depths of
yourself and and the world and you can
reciprocally open it would make sense
yeah and that's what Plato talked about
when he talked about the the myth of the
cave you know and we turn that into the
movie The Matrix so right you can you
can you can wake up you can reciprocally
open up and what's what's important
about that is that's jumping into the
sky that's like a set the word for that
is in Greek is anagogue it means Ascent
like like when they're the the people
are in the cave right and they ascend
out into the into the real world and so
you can you can open up now what's
interesting about that is like when you
do that this was Plato's great Insight
three things are happening that are
really really important
two well I'm gonna use mad again two
meta desires so in addition to whatever
you desire you desire that what is
satisfying your desires you have peace
of mind you have you're not at war with
yourself you're not in conflict with
yourself okay the other is
you desire that what is satisfying your
desires is real you may say well that
doesn't seem right well let me let me
let me let me let me give you just one
clear example of this
so we've tried to take everything that
used to be carried by God and Civic and
sacred religion and culture and
tradition and Heritage and Legacy and
put it into our romantic relationships
they're going to do all of that for us
this is the weird messed up oh yeah we
we make someone our higher power that's
right that's right and we and we'd say
to one person you're going to do all
that for me and they can't and so the
relationships break inevitably because
our expectations were insane your
relationship shouldn't be your ultimate
right your relationship should be
nourished by what is Ultimate that's a
different thing right so you ask people
I do this with my students they'll say
how many of you are in deeply satisfying
romantic relationships that so a certain
number put up their hands
and I say
of the ones that have their hands up
right now keep Your Hands Up
if you would want to know if your
partner was cheating on you even if that
would destroy the relationship and
almost all of them keep their hands up
and then you ask them why do you keep
your hands up
and they said because it's not real
I wanted to be real I don't want it to
be a fake I don't want to be fraud I
want it to be real now what's happening
with this reciprocal opening the
opposite of the addict in which
everything's becoming unreal is they're
getting more and more integrated as a
person the world is making more sense
it's getting more real they're getting
more at peace and these open those are
the two things you're satisfying those
two things in a joint way and here's the
third thing when you do this with a
person or with reality
so mutually accelerating disclosure is
the technical term but if I open up to
you and then you open up to me and then
that enables me to open up more to you
and we do this reciprocal opening with
each other that's love that's what and
it doesn't I'm not talking about
romantic love it yeah right so buddies
yeah reciprocal opening
gives you peace of mind
gives you a deep reality and it causes
you to love that's leaping into the sky
um
yeah you notice I get that a lot when I
go so I'm I go to recovery meetings and
so I'll go to meetings and like one of
the things that's nice about it is
I sit in a room a lot of times and
people just share what's going on with
them right and everybody just listens
you just listen you don't even no one
replies to that person no one judges
them no one it's just this place where
somebody can share and whatever their
feelings were with that they can just be
in the room and there's no you start to
create this sense of comfort in people
that you can share this that the world
is a safe place to share which probably
was got closed up if they were really
you know like narrowing in and
isolating it's like so this thing starts
to grow and it's just like it's almost a
comfort it's just a comfort that grows
but then it it it becomes like a a
positive algae on other things and then
everything starts to grow a little bit
yeah and it really is it's expansive
though yeah it is very expansive is what
it feels like and expands out and in is
that is that fair yeah I agree that's
really what's interesting about it
you're like before you know it you're
kind of feeling okay a little and it's
uh but it grows on itself you know so
imagine if you're Siddhartha gatama the
Buddha right or perhaps Socrates and
that is how you were always living and
you you to the the the prob the answer
to the problem nihilism is not some
argument the answer is to fall in love
with being with reality again in this
way we're talking about and when you do
that
right
you get that vertical dimension
well let me tell your story right so
this is uh Julian Barnes wrote a book
The History of the World in 10 and a
half chapters there's this one story
about this guy dies and there's an
afterlife and goes to heaven Saint
Peter's is there oh and do whatever you
want and and the and and the good place
made use of this but I won't do any
spoilers but anyways
um the great ending they made use of
this and he you know he wants to play
and he gets and he plays golf and he
gets the place where he can play golf
absolutely the best every single day all
the time then tennis and then any
painting and then after a while he comes
and it's like
you know I'm kind of done
and he's like and St Peter goes good
good
think of what goodies the point of
Heaven is not for you to live forever I
always think of the line from Moby Dick
what is man that he should want to live
out the lifetime of his God right the
point of Heaven is for you to be ready
to die it's ready for it to cease to be
because you're Immortal you shouldn't be
forever and then stoicism is can you
live now so vertically
that you're ready to die not I'm like in
some stiff upper lip we misuse the word
stoic we think it's about being stoicism
is about Joy not pleasure it's about Joy
it's about this vertical jump it's about
this vertical like deep depth right can
you
have such joy in this way we're talking
about that you're ready to die
well that's a great question
it's interesting and then how would
people get there you know and how does a
man like you know how do people get to
that place today the responsibility I
think men are feeling a ton of
responsibilities right now yes it's very
hard and that's okay it's interesting
it's that's what that's what's being
brought on by the world and by Society I
think men are realizing that they have
to be the uh
I don't know if it's the ruler of their
Kingdom but they have to really start to
step up and be a leader in their home
and in their environment
I think it's really I mean for me
somebody that's been of help for me
um is Marcus Willis I mean so he's a
great stoic philosopher but he was also
the um the the Roman Roman Empire he
runs the whole Roman Empire he's the
last and perhaps the greatest of the
five good emperors and he said something
that you have to really let it
reverberate inside of you uh because it
really it he said many things if you
read his the meditation the meditation
chatty kind of yeah thank God yes well
the meditations aren't written to
anybody else they're actually if you the
Latin to him yeah they're written to
himself so he's doing a spiritual
practice and this is a practice you can
do by the way and it it starts to work
but one of the things he wrote to
himself he said it's possible to be
happy even in a palace
hmm
right and that that's so interesting
because you you think the last sentence
is going to be even in a prison or even
in a desert island or something right
desert island and it's like nope it's
possibly happy even in a palace and it's
like there's a way in which although all
those things that are catchy but don't
have depth
we can we can we can learn
and we can help each other
said the next boot is actually the
Sangha the community right we can we can
learn to discern
uh through all of that and get to it
where we can find that vertical
um uh such that we can leap into the sky
hmm
I love that man I love that feeling when
you're stuck you're painted into a
corner that you can still leap into the
sky there's a way to find fascinating
reciprocal opening there's a way and and
and and let's let's be clear I mean you
have Marcus relius on on one I'm not
saying still I have criticisms of
stoicism
um but you know Marcus Aurelius is an
emperor Epictetus is a slave the the two
poles and they're both saying you can do
this you've both they're both saying at
the extremes uh you can you can find
this
um and and they're not saying they're
not doing it like a Hallmark card yeah
right they're like you you have to you
have to practice a lot of PR you have to
do a complex Ecology of practices that
you not only do by yourself but deeply
with other people
homed properly and then you can make
progress on
doing this what we're talking about
where did we start to lose that I mean
obviously religion was something that
was big that kept people in like a
common like a common practice right that
was a and that was bigger in the past
centuries I feel like that has been here
in in America yeah well I mean and that
provided a place where you would go
together you would there were certain
practices that you guys did each week
and uh there were you know religious
get-togethers and and and people
thinking about their God and thinking
with their god
um and singing together yes singing
together stuff like that it's powerful
man I've been in a I've been in a church
where people will start even in an
audience with a band sometimes and but
it's specifically at a church tonight
people start singing It's like it'll
open up you know it'll make you feel
connected you know your feelings will
just start crying just start emoting you
know or feeling something yeah
um so there's something about that the
the doing something as a community and
feeling as a group yeah and also there's
the horizontal and like in some of the
practices that that we do
um there's the horizontal like you and I
reciprocally open to each other but
there's also the vertical you and I sort
of we're not only opening this way we're
opening vertically as well and it's
really interesting when you do some of
these Socratic practices uh dialectic
into dialogues philosophical Fellowship
things like that people who are often
not religious at all secular they'll get
into this and they'll start to feel that
Collective Flow State and that sense of
oh reciprocally opening to each other
and then they all start talking about
like the the third the we space like the
the collective intelligence that neither
it's not coming just from you or for me
but it's being co-created and emerging
and taking on a life of its own yeah
right and then they start to talk about
this in in religious language and and we
we lost that I mean so that feels like
as close as we can get to God a lot of
times I feel like there's the best
people start saying things like that it
might be God for them and I I want to be
really careful here I'm very respectful
of people's religious adherence I'm not
anti-religious by any means
um but um no neither but people well
what happens is right and this this is a
a platonic point a neoplatonic point so
what happens is
initially when they're doing these they
get an intimacy with each other that
reciprocal opening they fall in love
it's finally I love it's not like but
that's in the word philosophy it's
Fellowship love of wisdom right they get
that and then they start to feel
intimate with this the Geist the spirit
we call it the logos the the right this
this thing this emerging collective
intelligence that is making everything
more intelligible and people start to
reciprocally open with it right and then
they start to reciprocally open through
each other and through that logos
to the depths of reality yeah and then
they start to feel like they're in
relationship to what's his ultimate and
some people think about that as God and
and some and some people think about God
personally some people think about God
impersonally some people think about it
more like the ground of being or
Ultimate Reality but what everybody
starts well all the people that talk
this way what they're doing is they're
trying to express
a connection to something that's
profoundly
transformatively real and meaningful and
we have a word for that it's sacred to
them how and there's a deep connection
between having a sacred canopy and the
cultivation of wisdom so another thing
I'll ask my students where do you go for
information without thinking they hold
up their
smartphones because we're all cyborgs
now right right and I say where do you
go for knowledge and they'll sort of
like oh how well science the university
but yeah something right but then I'll
say and this is where it's really
interesting where do you go for wisdom
and there's an anxious silence
now if you'd asked people that 200 years
ago they'd say oh my church my temple
my mask
right right right by Sanger
those answers don't come out
occasionally
very rarely somebody will say like my
church but sometimes they'll they'll say
it kind of like but not really
and what's happened is
it's most so the the the largest growing
demographic are the nuns the n-o-n-e-s's
they have no affiliate official
religious identity now that doesn't mean
they're overwhelmingly atheist most of
them are spiritual but not religious or
Seekers or they have weird Supernatural
beliefs but so but
what's happened is most people are
abandoning religion not primarily
because they've come to some deep
conclusion that it's false although
religion has a problem the religions
generally have a problem with the
scientific worldview at least some
versions of them but it's much more it's
it's it's it's a little bit of a truth
issue you know but it's much more a
relevance issue most people feel that
these institutions are no longer like
relevant to them they're they're not
they're not vibrant they're not vital
yeah they they don't speak to them they
don't call them to their better self
they don't call them into like these
these the these these experiences in
fact the Ecology of practices has
generally withered and we've tended to
emphasize like giving each other
propositions and reciting them to each
other as opposed to
this complex set of rituals and colleges
and practices so yeah we as we lost and
I'm not and I'm not Nostalgia you can
put this on my Tombstone neither
Nostalgia nor Utopia I'm not Nostalgia
I'm not saying we need to go back right
right no we're just looking at it right
we're looking at it but when we lost
that sacred canopy we we lost a lot and
you know Nietzsche said it really well
he said he runs into the marketplace The
Madman
and he's he doesn't confront Christians
he confronts the atheists who are all
sort of tittering about the death of God
and he said you don't know what and
Mitch is the guy who pronounces the
death of God so he's not he's not there
to argue against them as atheists he
said you don't realize what you've done
you've taken a sponge and you've wiped
out the sky right you've Unchained us
like we're no we're forever falling we
have to become worthy of this we like
killing God we have not like to put it
in affective terms we have not grieved
to the depths we need to and in a
healthy way in order to be worthy of
that that's what he's basically saying
well yeah it's like if you when you take
that type of thing away right I mean and
then you take away the religion of the
family right like a lot of families have
evolved you see a lot of single parent
families both parents have to work you
know the kids are being raised by uh you
know by their smart phones and by
whatever of the first thing you can get
in get to them and then you take away
also you know there was a time like in
the 90s where like uh everything kind of
like and this is a smaller version but
everything is like you can watch or
consume whatever you want when you want
it yeah there used to be like sure
experiences they would hold networks for
a reason right they were a network
together we would all watch a show and
then we would go out in the street and
like impersonate the characters from it
we would uh like you were excited as
soon as the show went was over
especially in the summer because it was
still light outside we go outside and
like impersonate our favorite acts from
it we'd all laugh and have like a shared
experience we whereas now everybody was
fragmented yeah everybody's just like
watching whatever when they want it's
all separate you don't really feel a
connection I think that's that's
profoundly right that's what I meant
earlier about how popular culture used
to have a religious religio to bind
together it's Lo it used to do that and
now we've even lost that Dimension I I
think I I think well how do we get back
from there do we get back from there or
is this like an evolutionary time where
how we meet and the things that the
glues that connect us or make us feel
like part of a society or part of a
universe or existence that they're just
being challenged like I mean a lot
they're always being challenged but do
you think there's a way out of this kind
of space or do you think we're in like a
never before I do think there's a way
out and I don't like so a big chunk of
my scientific work my work as a
scientist is to try and figure out what
is this meaning making Machinery what is
wisdom
um how can we get a better understanding
so we can cultivate it better but also
working with communities of practice
practitioners leaders of these
communities I've done a lot of
participant observation I've done a lot
of participant experimentation I did uh
rafik Kelly's return to the source last
July
um uh is that a series is that a uh you
go out and it's in a quality of practice
evolve move play he's been very
influenced first by Jordan Peterson's
work and then more so uh more recently
and uh I think you would say more in
depth by my work
um and we'll put links to all of these
things that he's mentioning and talking
about we're going to put links to those
in the uh in the information on YouTube
so you guys will be able to access these
different things go on sorry so so you
know and what what you have is you you
have
um
So when you say there's a father or
mother out there right yeah they're in
charge of their home right and they want
to have a different future they want
their you know what can what do they do
what do they start to do like all like
as a person
or as a leader of a home that can help
yeah so good good here's the answer uh
uh sorry uh
I'm enthusiastic don't misread my my
energy for like I know like I I hope I
have no we're waiting we're waiting John
okay so like and where this comes from
work I've done with Nathan Vanderpool
and uh and other people like like I said
I've done a boat I've I've been in the
room virtually or uh in person with all
of the scientists when we're all sat in
a room and we what is wisdom and we
really we produce the consensus paper
and then I've done I've go you know do
lots of participant observation and we
got all the a lot of the leaders of the
community together in one room and we
did a bunch of discussion and practice
and we're gonna I'm gonna go to another
one uh next week in France
um same thing and and so what's coming
out of it is like there's
sort of three dimensions you want to pay
attention to you want to pay attention
to view care and action you want to pick
remember that framing you want to do a
you want to really become aware of how
you're Framing and you want to be become
really aware of that process of how
you're assuming and assigning identities
stop letting all of that go on
mindlessly automatically reactively
trying you got to bring it more into
your awareness right that's View Care
reciprocal opening you've got to learn
how to reciprocally open how to you know
what communicate share information
accept information is that what you mean
by that yeah but also reciprocally open
you need you need one of the defining
features of wisdom is an ability to take
other people's perspective in a way that
makes a difference to how you're
behaving
I don't understand so you and I right
you can know that you can know as a set
of facts John's different he thinks
differently than me but you can have
this kind of moment let's say it's not
me where you go
oh
Oh I thought she was angry
but she's actually afraid hmm
you have to you have to cultivate that
kind of uh Daniel Siegel calls it mine
site like insight into other people's
minds and not just facts about their
mind but the ability to get their world
and where they're coming from so that
you can be responsive and responsible to
it um
you care and then that automatically
those two you can now see why they lead
to the third thing action how are you
interacting and you want to be doing
that so you can tune in to connections
how are you connected to yourself
how are you connected to other people
how are you connected to the world and
how are you connected to something
ultimate that gives a verticality to
your existence and then you want to
cultivate an Ecology of practices in
four
domains we call it dime you want
dialogical practices this dialectic into
dialogus and we run workshops on that
and there's a whole bunch there's
circling practices there's this is all
over the place where people are trying
to get back this kind what's happening
between you and I where it takes on a
life of its own and we both get to a
place we couldn't get to on our own and
it's emergent and it's transformative
yeah then you want the imaginal you have
to remember we talked about the
experiment with you have to learn how to
properly use your imagination again yeah
that's disappearing huh that's an
extinct animal the imagination and we're
also what and we've also we've also
relegated it to something that where
we're looking I want to compare two
different senses of imagination one is
the imaginary this is Henry corband he's
uh he was a philosopher
um and that's like when I you picture
something in your mind like picture a
sailboat yeah okay does it have are the
sales up or down in a shop okay so there
you go now that's one thing now I want
you to consider consider that in
comparison to this so a kid picks up a
stick ties a blanket around them and
says I'm Zorro they're not picturing
anything in their mind what they're
doing is they're trying to take the
perspective and the identity the stuff
we were talking about earlier of Zorro
they're trying on what it's like to be
Zorro in order to see if they can catch
any of his virtues
that's a serious play that's what you do
in ritual you do that imaginably
augmented
awareness so when I'm teaching people
Tai Chi right and they're novices you
have to teach them how to inhabit their
body differently you say to them okay I
want you to imagine you're standing in a
shallow River and your knees to your
feet are sinking into the mud you want
to have that sinking feeling there your
knees to your your navel are like the
flowing water you want this to feel like
flowing water right and then from your
navel up this is like the air you want
it to feel as insubstantial as possible
and when people are doing that they're
imaginingly augmenting so they can
become aware of very subtle patterns
sensory motor patterns that they were
would otherwise be unaware of and they
can reinhabit themselves in a new way
and a new possibility a new
developmental pathway opens for them
that's the imaginal you have to and
that's what ritual properly does right
so do you need the dialogical you need
the imaginal you need mindfulness
practices you need meditative practices
and contemplative practices they're not
the same thing you need seated versions
you need moving versions you got to
create that ecology right and then you
need embodiment in practices you need
practices that involve you right knowing
through your body being embedded in your
environment negotiating with the world
so Rafe Kelly you evolve move play you
go you do Parkour in the wilderness so
you get nature connection and you're
also moving your body and having it be
challenged so it's not a postcard that
you sit back like a Monet painting oh
isn't that lovely I just really like no
it's challenging you it's forcing you to
transcend I when I was there I'm like
I'm like 60 and I'm there with all these
20-somethings right and like all right
and and uh and I talked about every day
you went to the Horizon of horror you
take and they were they're so good at
like taking you to this place where it's
like oh I'm really scared I made a vow
to myself I said no matter what it is
there's a couple things I can't do
because of my Meniere's and I took I
said other than those things anything
that's present it to me I'm gonna do it
and the more afraid I am the more I'm
gonna do oh yeah
I did that today I went I got in the ice
I have an ice bath here and I got in I
didn't really want to but I was like I
need something I just want to alter I
just want to challenge my perception
today yeah I want to do something I
don't want to do it's something small
but it's like doing that thing that you
don't want to do or putting yourself up
just committing to it you know
do you think we used to get so much more
out of that just in our system because
if it seems like these things you're
speaking of are things that seem like
Necessities to our soul you know they
are like nothing seems more thirsty
these days than like our soul like
whatever there's like some I almost can
feel this part of underneath me all a
lot of times just
almost like my soul is trying to order
per like
oxycons or someone's like dude what am I
like what am I even doing here anymore
if these are the practices we're doing a
lot of times it's like you can start to
feel it feels bored
you know or it feels like thirsty that's
a better word it doesn't feel bored it
feels thirsty well it yeah thirsty and
but it can vacillate between profound
boredom and extreme anxiety like so you
get the and by the way thirst that's the
that's the the word that's actually used
in the Buddhist scriptures for what's
usually translated as desire it's more
like thirst and craving it's not a
simple desire yeah uh so yeah and that
that craving
um
it's that reciprocal narrowing it's
identifying in a Mindless fact it's all
that stuff we talk about yeah and
I I like I like the contrast that I'm
I'm playing around with it in my mind
it's like we have to learn to not thirst
because we properly nourish our souls
and when you get people to do these
for like these three dimensions of view
care action and do dime you know
dialogical imaginal mindfulness embodied
embedded extended and acted all that
stuff emotional too all the ease right
right and they do it not only
individually but collectively
right
then people start to talk about that
nourishment and that nourishment that's
where the the language you're you're
soul is sort of your vehicle your way of
being profoundly connected right
and sometimes people make a distinction
between your souls sort of how you're
profoundly connected like to your body
and to and you're grounded and then your
spirit is how you're profoundly
connected to that capacity for leaping
into the sky right and and then yourself
yourself is paradoxically how you're
profoundly connected to other we only
become selves through other people
if you're if you're raised in isolation
you don't become a self you don't become
a person we become selves we become
selves by I I'm taking a perspective
right now right and you're taking a
perspective on my perspective
what a kid does and this this is like
the Zorro the imaginal the kid
imaginably not imagine imaginatively but
imaginately right
the kid will try and take on the
perspective of the teacher or the parent
that's why and they'll imitate them
right and eventually they can imitate
them to the point they indwell that that
parent's perspective and then they
imitate it more and more and more
and what that means is they start to be
able to do that for themselves they
start to internalize that and what what
does the parents perspective have that
the kid's perspective doesn't the
parents perspective can see the biases
that's the kids perspective has if the
kid can't see it because they're in the
bio they're in the perspective and the
parents perspective can also see broader
deeper goals that the kids perspective
can't see and so this is by bigotsky and
other people's Notions by internalizing
the perspective of the parent
they get a capacity to take a
perspective on their own perspective
taking and that's how they start to
become a self-aware agent if you ask a
three-year-old even a three and a half
year old what's going on in your head
right now they'll say blood
they they can't introspect oh yeah but
and I I get I kept track of this with my
younger son it must be bad if your
father is a cognitive scientist but oh
yeah the kid's not gonna
but I kept track of the first time the
first two times he introspected he was
four and a bit and we were driving in
the car and he said Daddy it's snowing
outside but only in my head
and he oh he's imagining it right and
he's he can introspect he's got that
interior imaginal space because there's
no literal space inside your head yeah
and then the other time as he came up to
me and he said I have a backwards camera
in my head and I went what what does
that mean and then I realized he was
saying
he has autobiographical memory he can go
he can remember his past and then I this
is great I said to him does anybody else
have that and he said no only me
right so we become capable of
introspecting reflecting on ourselves
correcting ourselves contending
ourselves through other people we become
selves through each other and so the
soul is perhaps I mean I'm I'm trying to
rehabilitate these terms so we can
re-inhabit them and there's a connection
between those two words rehabilitate
reinhabit right I'm trying to
rehabilitate the notion of Soul this is
how we right this is our deep
connectedness to our embodiment to our
groundedness our self is our deep
connectedness to each other and our
spirit is our deep connectedness to the
vertical to what is Ultimate and if we
could bring those back so that they can
be simultaneously scientifically
understood
member Socrates and spiritually
transformatively real for us again then
we can do that nourishment you were
talking about and I think it's going to
become it's a necessity I think it is
that's what I think it I don't know if
that part of us can die the part of us
that is desperate
for
um
these just like this understanding or
this Comfort or this peace not even like
the comfort of a blanket or of uh but
the comfort of just some connection to
this greater energy that we're supposed
to be yeah like working with
you know
um
so we're just talking about like how
that that we need each other right yeah
we need each other and what's
interesting I've noticed about
time recently especially since like uh
social media and the computer really
since the smartphone is
we almost
I started to notice this with reality
television right like
so people would watch
a show
that was on reality television do they
have it in Canada yes so people would
watch it we pretty much have everything
you have okay
um well you don't want everything we
have no no and we also get some of the
stuff that we we don't want to have but
we still get it anyways I'm sorry and I
want to apologize yeah
um but like people originally where they
would watch a reality show because the
shows were like trying to capture like
people in their real lives behaving a
certain way
but then after like a generation had
gone on for some of those shows that
were still on and all became
yeah well the people were now they'd
seen people behave a certain way so they
were now just
being the characters that they'd already
seen they went on script yeah right and
they don't even do it by by
well you couldn't really have reality TV
anymore because the people that grew up
watching it were now just impersonate
they were impersonating what they'd seen
yeah so now the next contestant a
generation later on these same shows
were just impersonating what they so I I
just and I noticed it even with like
trends like they'll have on social media
people would be like okay we'll do this
dance do this thing I just wonder do we
start to get in this because of the
mirror of social media and of our cell
phone where we're just impersonating
yeah where we're not even
like how far are we getting from like
original ideas and thoughts if if if
generation over generation we just start
to impersonate what we've already seen
yeah I mean and that's a problem Plato
actually starts worrying about that
problem way back just immediately with
the invention of writing uh and
alphabetic writing yeah I mean
what one of the things that happens is
um
like beaudryard and you know we we hyper
reality we start to get we start to get
our capacity for abstract
imaginary symbolic thought which is one
of our great gifts yeah is also it's
adaptive so it is also something that
can be a vehicle of tremendous
self-deception it can cut us off in
powerful ways and one of the ways in
which that ability can
get sort of Twisted and hijacked is um
it's an idea from Eric Fromm
that he got from the stoics we were
talking about this Civics earlier
um and so remember I was talking about
you know we're always assuming
identities and assigning identities and
I have an agent Arena relationship
that's my existential mode
I'll just that's the that's the language
we use we're talking about that okay
when you say agent Arena what does that
mean that means that means I I'm
assuming a certain identity so I can act
as an agent I can pursue goals solve
problems so right and the arena is I the
world has the world makes sense and is
shaped so I don't go I don't go in with
a tennis racket with my tennis skills
into a football stadium right I see what
you're saying like when I go into a gas
station I go in there and I I'm a patron
so I don't act like a police officer
when I'm exactly exactly like a patron
in a gas station because that's what
fits the world that I'm in so that's the
agent in the arena and we can often
forget that uh and so one of the
personal problems I've wrestled with I'm
still wrestling with it is I will tend
to carry the professor Persona into
areas where it doesn't belong right and
so that's what I mean of when we're
doing it unconsciously right okay so
that's your existential mode when you're
doing all of that is that okay okay and
so from talked about sort of two modes
we have and the modes are both needed
uh and they're and they're both
organized around different kinds of
needs so one Modi called the having mode
this is the mode the in which you need
to have something you need to have water
you need to have oxygen and it means you
need to control it consume it and you
you need to have a categorical
relationship with it like like water it
just has to be water it doesn't have to
be like this particular one it just has
to be healthy water right and so what I
what I do is I'm manipulating and I'm
using my intelligence and I'm
manipulating and controlling the world
and I I have what boober would call an
eye it relationship I'm only relating to
this as an it as as a as a member of a
category right
and that's important because like if you
don't if you don't have that mode you're
dead Okay now there's another mode he
called it the being mode I'm not totally
thrilled with that this is the mode
these are the needs that are met not by
having something but by becoming
something so you need to be mature
you need to be in love notice how we say
we have sex but you want to be in love
right
um and and that's a different mode so in
that mode I'm not trying to control and
manipulate the world I'm trying to
reciprocally open it so I I strive to
have that relationship with my friends
and most importantly with my best friend
and partner Sarah right if I treated
sorrow like a member of a category well
Sarah the reason I'm with you is you
remind me of all the other women I've
been with I know how to manipulate and
control you and use you to satisfy my
needs that just ended the relationship
what she wants is no no you're not a
problem that I'm going to solve you're a
mystery that I'm going to constantly be
faithful to right
and and that and that's where I'm using
not my intelligence I'm using from means
reason but in Plato's sense not in the
modern logical sense he means that
capacity to challenge self-deception and
to try and reciprocally open with
something so those are your being needs
right
and those are important too and you need
both right because you want to have
water and you want to be mature you want
food and you want to be honest right
um
the problem we get from says especially
if we're not paying attention to our
existential mode is we will pursue
the needs in the wrong frame
so for example
being need maturity
instead of I'm going to become mature
I'm going to have a car
instead of being in love I'm going to
have lots of sex I see right and this
this is modal confusion your existential
modes are confused and when that happens
we confuse so quantity on equality kind
of yes yes kind of a blanket statement
but as yes so let's back to your point
social media what you want is you have a
being need you need to be in
relationship with people but now you
have connections you need to be real but
now you have a script do you see what
keeps happening what happens and and
prompts point is our culture right is is
largely he called it the like
problems of marxist I'm not a Marxist
but he he called it the market character
right he he said what what happens is we
we are increasingly LED
to trying to pursue not only our having
modes but all of our being needs from
within the having mode because if I can
get you to pursue your being needs
within the having mode I can sell you
stuff I can sell you stuff I can sell
you ideas I can manipulate you with
political ideas so there's a lot to be
gained by bullshitting you right
constantly keeping you with salience but
you don't ever pursue the truth of what
your needs really are right but
constantly giving the salience and
drawing you in right but but there's a
we benefit that in a way because if I
continue to bite at the
Fool's Gold bait right of those types of
things if I continue to it keeps me away
from really having to look at myself yes
so because it can be very painful to
really sit and look at myself and my
history and my past if I'm not doing it
in a loving way in an accepting way and
think about how that's made even worse
that's that's astute what you just said
so there's a there's an outer dimension
of how we're being misled and then
there's the inner dimension of how we're
avoidant and think about how hard it is
for you to confront pain if you don't
have a sacred canopy an ecology is a
practice that can give meaning to the
pain people can undergo tremendous pain
it is if it is made meaningful to them
I'm I'm working with somebody right now
she's done interventions around pain
management and like like people like
people think about here let me give you
a reason so what are the things people I
want money and I want to feel
comfortable I want to feel sort of good
uh you know I want good sleep good
health you know I want my partner to get
along really well you know what will
destroy all of those have a kid
have a child your health goes down your
finances go down right you're sick all
the time you're wet for some reason all
the time there's alarms going off you
don't sleep each part each partner's
each partner is convinced the other
one's not doing enough work and you ask
people why do you do that why do you
give up on all of those things and
they'll say because having a kid is so
meaningful remember I'm connected to
something that has a reality and a value
beyond my egocentric concerns I wanted
to exist even if I don't and I want to
care for it I want to make a difference
and it's magical like if you love a
child right you turn this
being I mean they're morally people
right from the beginning but you
cognitively they're not people yeah
right and you it's it's like magic you
love them and they turn into persons
yeah right and like it's just right and
so
when people can go they will sacrifice a
lot if they have a reasonable hope that
they'll be meaning in it but if we're in
a meaning crisis and meaning scarcity
they won't make any of those sacrifices
they won't face pain don't tell somebody
face your pain feel your emotions if
they can't bring meaning to it if they
can't have practices to confront it and
bring wise to sermon so you're right it
makes it even worse so not only are they
being bullshitted from without they're
being starved your nourishment metaphor
they're being starved within of the
meaning that would allow them to make
that confrontation and you're right
those two things feed on each other and
we get really reciprocally narrow we get
really bound into this profound modal
confusion and like you said it's Fool's
Gold it's not actually satisfying it so
we pursue I need more cars I need more
sex I need more drugs whatever it is and
then we get lost in a profound way well
we're at the end of the line with it it
feels like I mean we're watching there's
television shows up called American
Greed it's like yeah we're sitting here
watching you know we're watching like
every hero becomes a villain because
they fall to their own devices of
um addictions or small things whatever
little things that they let Fester while
they were uh trying to achieve grander
it's like we're just realizing that
there's no I think the Avenue of this
capitalistic I don't know what it is I
can't figure out what it is that's let
us sew astray though sometimes but I
think we are as a group are realizing
that it's that we are astray it feels
like I think so too and you know and
from predicted he predicted that
eventually
are in he he made the argument that when
we're a profound modal confusion what we
would eventually do when he was part of
the person that inspired me when I made
that prediction I talked about earlier
is we will seek the last connection we
have with reality which is violent
destructiveness if I can't connect to it
the last connection I can have is at
least I will be the one that destroys it
wow
really yes
think of movie Joker right and just how
that movie's just it's almost like a
hymn to that yeah I mean take a look at
schools people walking into schools and
shooting people that's a symptom of the
meaning Christ look at suicide look at
yeah um you know we had a corner on and
he was saying the number one cause of
death and uh black communities is gun
violence and it wouldn't cause a death
in white communities is uh overdosing
yeah it's like people are just finding a
mean you know there's we're at it feels
like we're in a cul-de-sac see of Hope
in a way yeah I think so we're in a
place where uh like we're really we're
we're narrowed down we're locked in uh
but like I said there's also those are
all the negative symptoms right right
and I know and I hate to be that I don't
want to try to be too negative either no
there's positive symptoms too right uh
and like if you look I'm just using an
analogy if you look at a disease you
look not at only the negative systems
you look at how the body's trying to
heal itself how it's trying to repair
because that might give you hope
rational hope for how you could actually
cure the disease but you see other
things happen in you like and and even
in those things you'll see the mixture
so the mindfulness Revolution is like I
I think I was the first person to teach
about mindfulness academically at the
University of Toronto and I had to sort
of introduce it like within the middle
of another lecture and just talk about
my opinion there's actually a lot of
experimental work and right now
everybody talks about it there's
journals and but the mindfulness
Revolution is an attempt to start
bringing back the cultivation now it's
also getting commodified I mean we have
what's now called mcmindfulness
mindfulness if you look in in the
cultures like if you look in Buddhist
cultures or you even look back into
Christian neoplatonism the monastic
Traditions mindfulness is this Rich
Ecology of practices there's meditative
practices contemplative practices right
there's cited practices there's there's
all this right and then what we did is
we took one practice meditation
sediment meditation and we said that's
all mindfulness is and then we took it
out of that rich thing we took it out of
the broader framework of ethical
practices and philosophical practices so
it's not about transforming you in the
world it's about making you contented
with being a corporate being a corporate
drone right and so but still there's a
positive you see what I mean there's a
positive and negative in there the
stoicism is going through a huge Revival
right now right there's there's like
there's a Revival of interest in Eastern
Orthodox Christianity because I think
one of the reasons I've had great
conversations with both Jonathan pajo
and Bishop Bishop Maximus both good
friends of mine
um because Eastern North Christianity
has the imaginal in it and has
neoplatonism in it so imagine if you
took Plato and Aristotle and the stoics
and you integrated them together so Not
only was it a great philosophical system
it was a profound Ecology of practices
that's neoplatonism and that's what's
coming back I consider myself a
neoplatonist right and so there's
there's lots of there's all these
biological communities emerging there's
things like race evolve move play
there's guy send stocks circling there's
the work that Taylor Barrett does like
all the stuff we're doing and we're just
one amongst many yeah it's well it's
interesting to hear people you know yeah
people are thirsty for something they're
thirsty for something new I think or
they're just a new being and they're
thirsty for something but you know
that's a thing and Plato had this weird
thing where he said you don't really
learn it's you're just always
remembering something you didn't know
but you did know it's just and people
have sort of struggled with this but
here's something that people say when
we're doing like the dialectic into the
logos or the philosophical Fellowship
they'll say things like
that's a form of intimacy I never knew
about but I realized I've always been
looking for um
that's what they say and it's so and
that's so paradoxical to hear but when
you're in it you understand perfectly
what they're talking about
they broke that modal confusion they
break through it Dirk Brook they br you
know Meister record they break through
it right he's a Christian Neil plainness
they break through and they break
through the modal confusion and so they
were hungry for it but they're framing
hadn't been well that's one of the
things I love about going to a lot of
different recovery meetings sometimes
you sit in there you're just waiting for
somebody to say something the way that
you have always wanted to say it but you
couldn't put like the seven or eight
words isn't that a gift when that
happens it's unbelievable
and I'll go three or four times a week
just hoping to hear one guy says
something and I will literally feel like
my body will do that and you can hear
someone's hear other people in the room
it's almost like that's the embodiment
to give sigh yes that's amazing yes
that's the embodiment right and that's
the soul right and there's also the
spirit you're both getting to a place
you couldn't get to on your and and I'm
going to use this word and I and I don't
I mean it positively and I'm not trying
to slot you but you know those are the
recovery meetings I I've done you know
I've I've attended a and some other
things uh but and many of them are
explicitly at least were born in a
religious frame but they're religious
practices in the way we've been talking
about you're cultivating wisdom and
transformation how to face yourself how
to cultivate connection right this is
and you're doing it individually and
collectively right and yes and and and
and and and I notice
and this is not this is an observation
it's not a criticism like you keep
returning to this as a lived example in
your body lived example of what we're
talking about yeah right and so but what
I'm asking you to now consider is
there's lots of possibility there's lots
of variations on this theme that are
arising everywhere and they're getting
scientific understanding they're
networking into a a subculture and that
gives me rational hope
yeah well I mean I think it's it's the
it's the thing like when things get bad
they're always
throughout time it seems like there's
always been like uh
in every story there's the moment where
you think things are where things get
bad and they get good it's like it's
that feeling inside you that this has to
end well I think that that little pilot
light of that yeah it feels like it
perseveres no matter what you know
um well it can get blown out uh but we
do some work with I agree with you about
that pilot light and by the way think of
it not just as a pilot light but like
what a pilot used to be or a pilot of
airplane or Pilot of a ship right it's a
Guiding Light right well I think it's
not even my own pilot light but I think
it's the collective that that's the one
that I feel like wins in the end yeah I
don't know if us as individuals if we
win that's an excellent distinction
because we're doing some work myself in
some uh my colleagues graduate students
of vets who have post-traumatic stress
disorder and their their internal
light and in some sense been blown out
but I like what you said one of the
things we're trying to do is see if they
can catch it from each other again
and try and bring about interventions
that can bring that about so remember I
mentioned Paul tillick the courage to be
he had a there's a Greek word for this
and it's from the Christian tradition
um it's Kairos and it means it it means
the right timing that where the the time
we're time where the course of things
turns and the Kairos is always a place
in which multiple opportunities so like
you know the you know the Bronze Age
collapse civilizations can collapse too
right and so right yeah we're at this
very crucial time now the the it's a
dangerous time
but the advantage of a Kairos is okay
when everything is going really well a
system is really stable and it has a lot
of inertia and it's hard to make a
difference but when things are breaking
up this is called self-organizing
criticality then individuals can make a
difference that they can't you normally
make one thing so don't look at like
well things have always been this way
because if we're actually in a crisis a
Kairos then Your Capacity as an
individual to make a difference has been
increased wow man that's awesome you
know that's really awesome man and
that's something that I think yeah I'm
grateful to hear that today you know and
I think and not to give us the Insight
that we are gods or that we but just
that you can this is never has the road
been set more when you can have an
impact that's right you know because
that's just the way that the chips are
stacked so what a blessing for you to be
able to have an impact right now if you
do something good if you do something
positive if you choose to take the road
that builds up your um self-worth more
than the the just uh feeling good in the
moment you know
um that's that's inspiring man when you
think of like
what about like love like people look at
love a lot you know have you been in
love before I'm in love right now okay
so you have a partner now and y'all have
children no I I've I've I have children
from a previous marriage she has
children from previous marriage and
we're we're done we've raised children
her tell children who to her two
children are adults My Two children are
now adults okay but y'all have you've
had children though yeah and there's
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
um and uh but I am in love now
um and I also love uh like uh my kids
and I love my friends
um but but I've also been learning to
love the world
and reality and being and in that sense
like Agape you know the love that makes
us like we're talking about earlier the
love that turns us into human beings you
know the the Bible I'm not a Christian
but the Bible said you know God is agape
like finding that reciprocal opening
that sacredness finding the Deep
connections between logos that Spirit of
making sense of things that emerges
between people the Agape by which we
make each other into people but it also
connects us deeper to reality the the
deep within is calling to the Deep
without and they call to each other I'm
in love with all of that yeah
did you um
do you think that uh
Theo I think I think if if you ask me in
the elevator John you have 20 seconds
this is what I would say learn to love
wisely
that's it
like it's really hard
or most of my failings have become that
I did not love wisely I love foolish I
think you could understand sin as a
failure to love wisely hmm
sorry I interrupted you but I just want
to know I just wanted to express that no
I appreciate you expressing that yeah I
think I've done that a lot of times I
think sometimes it's there's things that
are easier to love and it's not even
love it's not even love it's like a lust
even of your imagination yeah or even if
you can anything can lust it doesn't
have to be just like of your groin or
whatever you know yeah it can be of of
any you can fail Fame yeah Fame food
food sugar oh yeah I went through that
yeah yeah yeah oh god dude I eat a whole
bag of damn Dove dark chocolate
and I'll do it again sometimes I miss
the chocolate it's one of the things I
had to give up when I was diagnosed with
diabetes oh god dude they get you
um yeah how crucial is that to people to
to the success of their survival do you
think
love
well I I mean again
lust it lust is when we're pursuing love
from the having mode right okay so you
you need to have sex like I mean we got
into the mistake of thinking no no we
don't need that that and that mess that
messes people up yeah right and then we
do the other thing no no no no you need
like you'll get loved by just having
lots of sex and that now we're in that
the other we just went the other way
right and so I mean love is
the thing is we're really confused first
of all love isn't a Feeling
um you know uh I'm in love with Sarah
right now and until I mention those
words I wasn't feeling anything right
right love isn't an emotion uh I'm in
love with Sarah and sometimes that makes
me sad I miss her right now a lot right
sometimes it makes me angry you're
threatening Sarah I'm no you're not
gonna do that right and sometimes it
makes me really happy sometimes it makes
me very thoughtful wow
I I just realized I really don't know
her and that's wonderful so love isn't
even an emotion love is an existential
stance it's I am you and I we're gonna
religion we're gonna bind ourselves so
we reciprocally open so you draw the
best out in me I draw the best out in
you you transcend yourself through me
and I transcend myself through you and
we keep realizing that that is such
amazing mystery that keeps happening
we're going to be faithful to it it's a
commitment yeah it's a commitment but
it's it's not a commit like the Greeks
had there's not a prison no but and the
Greek side the Greeks have two words
right there's incratia like democracy
kratia power so incredia is when you you
commit by like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna eat the chocolate I'm not gonna do
it I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna do
it that's In Crowd here
cypherson suffer sin is different
so for instance like this
um Saint Paul talks about what he does
the Hindu Agape when I was when I was a
child I thought like a child I acted
like a child but then when I became an
adult I put childish things behind me as
the child is to the adult the adult is
to the sage right so when when you're a
kid you have two Gods candy and toys in
fact one of the greatest things I did
philosophically with when when my with
my younger son is I came to him one day
and I said which is more important toys
or candy and he looked at me like
finally dad is asking me something
intelligent and even even like even did
like give me a moment I want to think
right I was like okay and then he came
back to me and he said
toys because you can get sick of candy
and I thought oh that's my son all right
there's a philosopher in there somewhere
right
um and so right but notice what I used
to play with him all the time and it's a
weird thing when you're an adult because
like I remember one of my friends told
me he remembered the day when the toys
died when the like because what happens
is when you're when you're a kid toys
are super Salient to you right my my son
when he was young he used to have that
like a toy tower all the MC figurines
are there and everything like in like to
get him he would forego urinating and
eating to play right with his toys right
now I would play with him but I don't
have that you know because I'm I hope
I'm an adult I'm a man and I don't have
to sort of resist I don't have to go no
I won't play with the toys no I won't
I've matured what I find Salient we call
that a salience landscape I've matured
what I find Salient how I connect to
things and Salient means just to make it
clear how things grab your attention how
they stand out for you how they catch
you got it right and so like I know
logically I could pick up the toys and
play this is Mark but it doesn't it
doesn't draw me
you you want it you want to commit not
incratically I'm not going to cheat on
my partner you want to increase you want
to commit suferson it's like I'm
constantly tempted by the good I'm
constantly flowing it it comes like
second nature to me to to have this
commitment like Frankfurt called la love
a voluntary necessity which is a
brilliant way of putting it see what I
mean because we have the the the problem
we've we have
is we can
and and this this messes people up
that's why this is why I wanted to speak
to this we people I think commitment's
the right word the problem is we often
when we hear commitment we think of Duty
and then we fall into a cradia and we
I'm going to force myself to stay with
this person right now you have to tough
it out at times but like in the end you
want to mature in a relationship so that
the commitment is sopherson right and
right so it's reciprocal yeah and it's
opening and you're being drawn into it
rather than forcing yourself it's like
it's like when you're meditating
initially you're sort of constantly
trying to keep your attention on the
breath and it's like concentrate like
the word you're forcing things into the
center right but what you get is you get
to the where it flips and instead of
doing that you're constantly instead
being re-interested and being drawn into
what you're focusing your attention on
entering the stream as they talk about
right you want to enter the stream in
your com love it like infatuation is the
the the the momentary Madness that gives
us a foretaste that we can properly play
with of how that can happen but the
problem is we can't stay in infatuation
you have to what infatuation does is it
says okay see how you could get into
this reciprocal opening with somebody
now this is candy
find out how to make it food basically
that's the other problem we have in our
culture the romantic comedies have told
us that the most important not only do
they tell us that this weird
story that the universe will
conspire to bring you the person you
should be with no it won't
yeah the universe is not like one of the
it's not like a lazy Susan no exactly
and the other thing it tells you is
right the best part of Love Is the is
the Falling in Love Part no it's not
infatuation right infatuation is to
shake your world up enough right so that
you could cultivate that commitment so
that it becomes you're constantly
tempted to fall in love with the person
again and again and again and that's
what I thought was interesting as you
said in the beginning was that when you
were talking about your partner about
your wife
um that you said if there's something
new I see about her or that she's a
mystery you know
continuing to perceive that person is a
mystery really or to look at them as a
mystery it just makes it it's going to
make every day or every week whatever
like a new episode it's not gonna you're
not gonna just be playing the same
episode over and over again you're
giving your framework your framing as a
as a perspective to oh let me see what
else knew I could learn or see about
this person or a new way that I can
relate to them that's pretty fascinating
well so confronting a mystery
confronting a mystery rather than
here here
this is what will this is this is how
you know your relationship is doomed if
you turn your partner into a problem to
be solved
rather than a mystery to constantly face
and be faithful to
wow to be faithful to a mystery too
that's a pretty brave thing you know
well exciting it's cool it's cool though
I think it's neat I think that's the
what I again try to rehabilitate the
notion of Faith instead of Faith being
asserting propositions pretending you
have certainty even though you don't
have evidence what about we reconsider
Faith as faithfulness to the mystery of
being so that we continually fall in
love with reality in increasing depths
within and without why don't we make
Faith faithfulness as opposed to I'm
going to say things that have no
evidence and I'm going to pretend that
I'm certain about them I think that's a
that's a really modern and it's not the
ancient notes in their faith and that's
one of the things again we lost we've
lost faith as a profound faithfulness
do you think because you're a smart guy
do you think it is which is okay maybe
maybe some people are smart and that's
okay I'm not saying you're good at
volleyball you know you might not be you
might be bad at volleyball I don't know
but but some but some things are certain
people are some are certain things you
appear smart right okay to a pretty
regular person like myself is it harder
to be in love when you're smart like
because smart makes it so you kind of
look at things a lot you know
um so intelligent people uh generally
have a harder time
um and the problem and this is the work
of stanovic and others the problem we've
also gotten into is we've confused being
intelligent with being rational and
we've confused being rational with being
logical and so we get all messed up
about this intelligence is your capacity
to solve problems rationality is
ultimately I would argue and this is the
ancient notion this is Plato's notion
it's not about being logical rationality
is about using your intelligence to
become aware of the self-deception and
the bias so that you can overcome it
that's what so mindfulness is a way of
being rational even though you're not
running any arguments in your head okay
so if you and Plato Plato was deep about
reason in that sense reason we still
carry it around when we talked about
somebody being reasonable right reason
in that sense and love they're
interwoven because reason in that sense
is the profound love and faithfulness to
what is true what is good and beautiful
and I think if you're intelligent and
you're not and you haven't cultivated
rationality and it's accompanying
virtues then
you are more and more tempted to
problematize your relationship just
because you have the intelligence
Machinery to to
but if you could so
but if you start making hurdles because
your brain that's what it just it likes
to solve problems so it'll just make
problems right and and what your brain
will also do right is your brain so your
brain is a a powerful prediction machine
it's a relevance remember we talked
about anticipating the future so your
your brain is constantly also trying to
solve problems you didn't solve in the
past uh and so yeah so in a bit of a
slogan your brain actually prefers
familiar unhappiness to unexpected
happiness because it likes organization
right it likes it likes it likes
familiarity because familiarity at least
initially seems that you're predicting
things now the problem with familiarity
is and you know this you know you see
you see this in your friends and they
see it in you and the the great the
great gift is if you could come to see
it in yourself you're doing that thing
Bill you're doing that thing you're
always doing your relationships you're
doing it again yeah right and and you
seem so wise from the outside except you
know two years later bill comes to you
and says you know Theo you know you're
doing that you're doing that thing again
right right now you're doing that man
right yeah yeah I know it's so
interesting so you you have to your
intelligence not only is problematizing
things by looking for problems it's also
trying to solve previous relationships
but in often in a maladaptive way
um but if you can bring
rationality in the platonic sense
rationality love virtue into
faithfulness
um and they're all interdependent if you
can bring that in then I think then it
shifts and that actually makes gives you
a greater capacity to enter deeply into
a loving relationship I I I I I like I
want everybody to understand I'm like 61
almost 62. and I've like screwed up a
young man well thank you I've screwed up
a lot
um and I continue I continue to make
sense so so
um
uh I want to give credit to a lot of the
people that helped me along the way and
I want to give credit to my friends and
also to my my beloved partner for like
for anything I'm saying here I I I I owe
it profoundly to them
yeah and we're just trying our best you
know it doesn't mean that you know
everything no and I don't want to come
across that way but I do about it so but
okay good but I also but I also feel
your questions deserve a you know the
best most responsible answer I can give
them no and I appreciate that yeah
that's what I'm hoping for
um yeah because I think that's a
challenging thing these days I mean
especially you know
we've let so much
cons like we've let so much and I don't
know if it's capitalism or what we let
when in our country we let those things
become more important like you know we
let like uh I mean I use pornography as
an example just how it killed it's
killed a lot of the libido in the world
yes I feel like and so there's no it
makes Salient as opposed to offering
depth see that and Han talks about this
in Saving Beauty
um he talks about how pornography makes
he talks about how we've we've tried to
make everything smooth we've instead of
see if you read the Ancients or even
realka beauty is almost terrifying
because it shocks you it wakes you up it
makes you oh I didn't realize the world
could be like this oh I remember I saw a
hot chick I couldn't even handle it dude
right yeah I try to almost bury myself
in the dirt one time because I couldn't
handle it the first time I saw it it's
overwhelmingly powerful and it's like 11
inches of dirt out and Saturn
that crazy though but it well like it's
it's
something that we've done everything
else to we've tried to like
uh what did what did Wilco say beauty is
the angel that almost threatens to kill
you but doesn't
um right and and then what what
pornography does according to Han is it
just makes everything there's no
Challenge and what that and we think
that's great because now it's easily
accessible I can have it but there's no
confrontation with mystery there's no
calling to go beyond oneself there's no
calling to challenge one so everything
is now smooth for us and we've we've
adopted an aesthetic of the smooth and
the easy and the comfortable I think
you're right pornography is a a you know
a clear symptom of just how and then we
and and and it said hyperbolic
discounting we get the the the the
momentary thing and we lose the
long-term project yeah the long-term
project of relationship cultivating
sexuality between yourself and a partner
yes it's like okay do I want to go out
and meet someone and try to fall in love
and try to covet them and respect affect
them and create sensuality and make this
long diatribe of a relationship that has
value to both me and them or do I just
want to go squeeze one out over here you
know yeah yeah and a lot of times you'll
just choose that easier when you'll just
buy a new Vape or something and choose
that easier when instead of go that
Longer Road where there's going to be
more value you know and it's almost
become so prevalent that some people
don't even know that there is the longer
Road anymore the fact that that's the
scary part yeah we're growing up in a
generation who has never been without
screens and and where pornography is
available all the time everywhere and
everything is if you want to laugh now
this is kind of an interesting one but
if you want to laugh you can go find you
a laugh you know you can find a laugh
pretty quick but if you wanted to be out
like we had to make each other like you
had to you had to be the videos you're
watching in a way you had to use your
image imagination to iterate what had
happened before like you had you felt
like a cog in the in the in the wheel of
um entertainment just by being a human
being and some of that has disappeared
you know
um I mean conversation is people are
listening to people have conversations
that's how archaic they're becoming so
that people are listening to podcasts to
hear people talk freely so one uh by the
way I loved seeing you that animated
that was really powerful so thank you
for sharing that with me oh thanks man
that was really yeah I didn't know it
was going to be so powerful to me but I
think it does I think I felt falling
victims so much to pornography
especially in my 20s that like dude it
just makes me mad you know yeah time
wasted and the ability to love wasted
and the ability to learn about love you
know I didn't have any other choice you
know but um I mean I maybe had a choice
but I wasn't aware yeah yeah for sure
but um anyway go on well I was just
gonna say that uh
one of the things that I'm trying to do
with the going with the podcast and the
videos but I'm also building in-person
things is build a bridge between those
so that when people see these because
they get comments all the time it's like
I wish I could be part of that com those
kind of conversation that kind of Dia
logo so I use the Greek word yeah right
and then we say well you can and here's
a place you can come where you can start
to practice it
um you know and either you can do it
through Zoom room and that still works
by the way which is really fascinating
because it's a scientist I wonder would
it would it work but it still does but
we can also do it in person and trying
to build that bridge so people can once
they see I want to be part of that I
want to participate in that like you
were just talking about with so much so
much life
there's a place they can go where they
can there's a bridge between
witnessing and wanting to be in such a
conversation and actually practicing and
participating in it yeah
yeah well there's also there's I mean
there's 12-step programs for everything
which is great and you know I go to some
of the meetings for they have like
intimacy and love addiction and some of
the names of the groups are a little bit
off sometimes but you can go in there
and listen to people talk about uh their
struggles with
um relationships and uh sometimes
pornography all different types of stuff
I met a buddy that was a flasher in
there so you get all the time I mean you
know some of it's kind of cool kind of
yeah I mean not cool you know but it is
kind of neat you never know a flasher
you know no one yeah yeah yeah you know
them yeah you know that's great and um
so yeah I think some of that's just the
the rooms that are out there that people
are sharing like what their life is like
and and getting better and recovering
from those things are pretty fascinating
um it's also at a time where it's like
yeah if you're willing to share what's
going on with you there's a ton of value
to that yeah I mean as long as it
doesn't turn into that thing we were
talking about earlier like the reality
shows where it just becomes some thing
that we can modify in order to put
another trophy of narcissism on our wall
right and see how special I am I can
disclose more than you can and that's
why I think that's why I I really
strongly challenge don't don't find
don't think that there's one thing you
can do that will be a Panacea you need a
whole bunch of practices all doing this
checks and balance you need to do it
with a bunch of different people coming
from different perspectives right and
only then do you have the chance that it
might not degenerate in that that
fashion yeah because I do worry that we
we're getting kind of like therapy porn
starting to emerge in our culture where
what you know what I'm going to do is
I'm going to just open up and share my
feelings right and it's like toward what
end are you cultivating virtue are you
overcoming self-deception are you
helping the other person to grow like no
it's just I'm gonna expose myself so and
that's you know right and it's like the
Flasher right yeah yeah and it's like
I'm gonna expose myself and
and and then what we'll do is I got to
see deeply into somebody and it oh it
was so smooth it was so easy it's
pornography it doesn't take any
commitment or challenge I don't have to
make myself responsible to that person
they'll just gush and all just drink it
in and I'm worried that that's growing
right now wow that's fascinating man
yeah because I worry about that
sometimes like not only in my own life
but yeah you see stuff like that I have
some friends that are vloggers and they
Vlog every minute of their lives yeah
yeah and you can see they start to get
like they don't even remember what
they're doing anymore they're performing
for constantly for an audience and
they're they start doing strange things
and almost become trapped in this yeah
manic episode you know it's that
reciprocal narrowing and that right and
and they're trying to have something
instead of become someone like yeah and
the fact that I mean that's another
symptom of the meaning crisis the fact
as you noted this kind of stuff is
spreading like a disease like yeah right
yeah
but there's always been diseases right
there's always been things that have
come along we've always gotten through
them
well yeah I mean sometimes
we got 300 like things like the Bronze
Age collapse you know uh 1177 BCE right
we've had
Bronze Age civilizations ancient Egypt
to Syria Babylon the hittite Empire the
Mycenaean civilization they all
collapsed all collapse all except for
Egypt Assyria almost collapses it
shrinks
um Egypt survives because one of my
favorite people of History just got a
book on him Ramses III he's uh he's a
military genius and he defeats the
invading people to see peoples in two
great battles and he's he's like he's
trying to hold up the whole Bronze Age
World on his shoulders uh but uh even
Egypt once he he gets assassinated and
once he's gone even Egypt goes into
clients so most of the Civil most more
cities went out of existence more trade
is lost more literacy is lost than any
other time in the western world even the
fall of the Roman the Western Roman
Empire was not as great as the Bronze
Age collapse wow so things can really
collapse now and then there's like
there's several centuries and you don't
want to be alive in the centuries after
the Bronze Age collapse they're really
really bad time to be a lot oh it gets
pretty sketchy it gets really bad but it
opens up possibilities and people start
to experiment they create new Psycho
Technologies alphabetic literacy
numeracy and that gives birth to the
axial age to people like Socrates and
Buddha and uh loud say
yeah it's almost like you just needed it
over time it's like that's the cycle
yeah there's some people who think that
that that uh that complex organizations
go through what's called self-organizing
criticality they organize and they build
and they get very complex and then they
get they can't they get too top heavy
like a like a pile of sand and then it
Avalanches that it all collapses but
that provides a broader base and then it
can build again even higher than before
yeah and it oscillates in that way yeah
some people have argued that a human
cognition seems to work in in that way
too yeah yeah
so
um you know what you you you can't solve
this problem and you you gotta sense but
you can't you're just framing it the
wrong way but you can't break out of the
wrong frame
um and and what often have to happen is
you have to break that frame you have to
like and sometimes breaking is really
really hard sometimes it's easy like
you'll do things like you'll say to
people you know uh what's the gray stuff
that comes from fire and they say smoke
and what's what am I doing with my hand
right now my arm oh that's a stroke
um and what am I doing right now oh
that's a choke and what kind of tree
grows from an acorn that's an oak and
what do you call the white of an egg and
they'll say oh yolk of course it's not
it's the white of the egg right you fall
into a frame and you get locked right
and sometimes the frames are fairly easy
sometimes the frames are really really
hard like you're you're deep in modal
confusion right oh yeah right and so
breaking that frame is like that that
Avalanche you have to break that frame
but if you if you don't break it to the
point of trauma if you break it in the
right way what it does is it it allows
the brain's capacity to self-organize to
reorganize from like a broader or
different base and then you get a new
frame and then you get that aha moment
and typically what happens at least
that's a a significant theory is
the activity is predominantly in the
left hemisphere which is your logical
sort of step-by-step fine-grained
well-defined problem side and you
realize oh I can't solve this problem
and it goes into the right hemisphere
which was for like prediction well it's
predation it's wide open attention you
you're trying to get a a wide picture
the big perspective and what you do is
you you go over there get a new bigger
perspective and then bring it back yeah
yeah oh that's cool
um
do you think sometimes like
you know he say if you put like you took
a bunch of sand right and just poured it
into this this glass right here right
this it would fill it up right yeah do
you ever think that there's a lot more
going on in the world but that us as a
vet like a vessel only can com can
understand so much
so that there could be so much more
happening out here but our ability to
understand is only it's this glass right
so that I I I I I would say I know
that's the case because of what we rely
on
um we so most of our problem solving is
not done as individuals uh you didn't
invent English I didn't invent English
you're not managing the electric grid
I'm not a manager managing you didn't
invent these microphones I didn't invent
them right you didn't make these chairs
you didn't build this building blah blah
blah blah blah blah we forget that most
of our Pro no one person can run an
airline or a railroad right right and so
what what you can show what actually
what what we seem to do I've done work
on this with Dan chappie we've
investigated the the scientists moving
The Rovers around on Mars but what our
primary adaptivity is
we plug into that collective
intelligence and that collective
intelligence can often grasp objects
that we can't individually so it could
be bigger than this right so like to
give you a clear example no one and I'm
not trying to get into Political
controversies right now uh but like no
one person can perceive or even measure
or track global warming it takes a whole
bunch of scientists with a whole bunch
of equipment all around the world
totally can't just be a some dude
guessing right and no one person this is
at Hutchence no one person steer
navigates a ship it's a bunch of people
and a bunch of equipment and they
navigate the ship right yeah and so so
we plug into
right the the intelligence of
civilization basically but the problem
is there are things that can even exceed
that because civilizations
probably face what's called
um General systems collapse what that
means is
so here's a civilization and it's it's
dealing it's growing and what it's doing
is it's solving problems and every every
time a new problem emerges it adds a it
adds a new piece on itself it you know
and it grows and it grows and it grows
and initially it's just it's good at
growing and it's solving more and more
problem the problem is as it grows more
and more and more think about a
bureaucracy or a government bureaucracy
as it grows more and more and more it
starts to become as complicated as
anything it's trying to solve in the
world does that make sense yeah and
eventually it gets so big that it can't
manage itself well enough to solve any
unexpected new problems and then you get
General systems collapse and it's making
its own problems and it's making its own
problems and and it starts to be and you
can you can tell when an institution is
cusping on that
um and I think the universities are
suffering this problem is when the when
when the like the bureaucracy starts to
become for its own sake rather than for
solving problems because it's much more
about manage and maintaining its own
existence right and the civil services
of some countries go down that route too
so I think we have an individual limit
and then we we deal with that by
plugging into the civilization but the
civilizations also have a threshold man
freaking existing bro it's complicated
yeah well the thing is it's complicated
but reality is actually complex uh
complicated is we we we we we we can
manage all the variables uh but there's
just a lot of them complexes we have
real uncertainty and then and there are
new emergent variables and they're
dynamically shifting their relationship
to each other reality is actually
complex and we create complicated
systems within and without in between us
to drill with that complexity but at
some point we get challenged and part of
what I think we need to face
that was a a distinction from Snowden uh
part of what we need to
do face and this is comes out in my
conversations with Jordan Hall and
others and this is something we're now
discovering in biology so
you can evolve a trait like this
creature is going to be faster or right
or taller or something like that but
while we're now realizing it and this is
what is it Owen Gilbert yeah I always
get the names the wrong way around right
you can also evolve your evolvability
which is you can you can evolve so you
can evolve faster or better than other
species really so you can mate with
someone who evolves well and make a
hyper well let's just you just brought
something up there
okay for billions of years
organisms are single-celled and they
reproduce asexually they just divide
right human beings reproduce sexually
sexuality reshuffles the genetic deck so
we get more variation
and with more variation Evolution speeds
up
so one of the reasons sex becomes
pervasive is it because it makes you
more evolvable as a species and now
using that analogy we have to learn to
become we're not we have to stop just
I'm gonna I'm gonna no sorry we don't
have we shouldn't stop I'm going to
become stronger or braver traits we have
to keep doing that but we have to do
this
higher order thing we have to we we have
to evolve our evolvability right now
because the the way things are
complexifying is accelerating
dramatically well especially in the US I
mean it's like we've become you know
it's a very I mean America's always been
kind of a
it's always been like a diversifying
landscape you know I think a lot of
people I know it's been tough for my
mother and for people of her generation
because they had like this idea of
America yes yeah and like of what it
stood for and the things we fought for
and the things that our brothers and
sisters died for you know those yeah all
of that yeah and those things a lot of
those things now people look at them and
the the news will scoff at those sneer
yes yes even sneer not even take into
account that some of these people died
died or that their loved ones had to
witnessed them die like yeah you know
um and a lot of those people start to
lose their uh hope you know yeah they
because they lose orientation right I
mean completely lose orientation which
is crazy like that's how much uh
comfortable landscape or common the
commonalities mean to people see the
landscape doesn't have to be comfortable
they were willing to go to war they were
real the landscape has to be navigatable
and navigation is not something you can
do primarily on your own right you have
to do you have to obviously Move
Yourself around right but you have to be
oriented and other people have to
cooperate in the orientation with you
and you help each other and that's how
you navigate a landscape and because of
what you just said we're losing another
way of talking about the meaning process
not being at home domicide is people are
feeling increasingly disoriented they
don't know which way to go yeah they
don't know what they should be doing and
so what they do is they fall into things
by default and I'm not criticizing
anybody no no this is normal
I just keep on keeping on and I just do
what I've been doing that's where I
think a lot of people are right now yeah
you know not only older folks but
younger folks as well
um
they're just wondering what I used to
think I was part of something now I
don't feel like that anymore looking out
for just myself feels
doesn't feel good it's very small yeah
it's very very small yeah it feels
really small I mean I think there's
moments of it where it's
it's nice in a way where you're like oh
I'm gonna have some self-confidence yeah
yeah of course I'm gonna achieve you
have to have self-care yeah man it feels
very lonely you know and I think a lot
of people are are kind of wondering that
so I wonder if that will lead people
back to
um religion looking for purpose and I
wonder why in America we've gone to like
Canadians I mean you're Canadian yeah
you know and thank you for being
Canadian I like them well John Oliver is
right about Canada right I don't like
John Oliver uh like a lot but when he
said that you know uh it's if as if the
United States and Great Britain had a
child that they abandoned in the snow
yeah right right so yeah I mean we lived
under
a superpower Great Britain and we slowly
negotiated a way out we didn't have a
revolution we slowly negotiated we don't
have life liberty in the pursuit of
happiness we have peace order good
government that's our that's our
constitution we slowly negotiated our
way out right and you can't point to a
point in history and say that's when
Canada was completely not a colony
anymore it's there maybe the statute of
Westminster in 1931 but like it's a
gradual thing right and and as we slowly
did that this superpower emerged to the
south of us that went on to conquer the
world I mean America is a Titanic entity
I mean like the second world war they
take on the Japanese empire almost
single-handedly while Manning most of
the Western Front and like it's Titanic
it's huge and there's just overwhelming
and they continue to be so like even
militarily you know you you take all of
the other NATO countries and pit them
against American Military the American
Military will destroy them in three days
like America is like like and Canada is
like we like imagine this there was a
superpower and we slowly managed to get
out of a shadow very carefully negotiate
only to have this other one emerge right
that overshadows us a power play and
completely so we're always we're always
in between we've always been in between
and we're always much more about because
we don't we can't enforce our way on the
world we're more much more about
perspective and negotiating we negotiate
with we negotiated with Great Britain
and we negotiate with the United States
and thankfully both Great Britain and
the United States
are willing and have been have been
uh willing to negotiate with us and to
Ally with us and you get you get to be
right there net you you kind of have to
have a Canada's always been a very
peaceful place I feel like a lot of my
friends are good listeners yes
um you know I think people are like
where like
I'm surprised it's not a Max a mass
Exodus to Canada
um but great posture too if you've ever
seen the posture in Toronto have you
seen it well yeah I mean part of it is
because you can slouch in winter when
you're wearing 10 000 layers of clothing
right you gotta you gotta bear yourself
well yeah oh and they do it you can
barely people just you could barely see
them they're so straight sometimes yeah
just like watching something go by
um
but yeah I find that uh that it's
interesting that we're finding like guys
like you Jordan Peterson
um and you guys work together
we were colleagues Jordan was just down
the hallway for me uh we continue to
keep in communication uh because he
doesn't teach anymore now does he no I
mean he had a very he had a very fraught
relationship with the university oh he
did yeah uh and uh uh yeah
um and I think there was fault on both
sides in that issue
um I mean but I want to be very clear I
have a really good relationship uh with
the University of Toronto they've
treated me uh well the psychology
department at least has treated me
extremely extremely well yeah right uh
but Jordan and I were were colleagues we
were very friendly colleagues uh we
shared students uh we we were we would
frequently find ourselves at the same
conference same conference talking about
stuff that's fun was it fun to discuss
things with him and be able to
communicate yeah yeah yeah
um and
I want to say this very carefully
because whatever you say about Jordan
Peterson it'll bite you in the ass no
matter what you say uh because Jordan
Jordan's a very divisive person but um
Jordan
and it's reciprocated Jordan respects me
and when Jordan respects you
he interacts with you differently that
if he doesn't respect you or he doesn't
know if he should respect you then he
interacts that this is at least to my
mind it could be a safety mechanism too
it could be a safety mechanism it could
also be that uh that's the kind of
teacher he was very care there were
three life-changing professors at the
University of Toronto uh one I won't
mention his name
um and the other two were myself and
Jordan Peterson and
um and so we often shared students
like I said I've always had I've always
had and I've appreciated very good
relationships with Jordan I don't agree
with Jordan on certain things especially
political things
um but you see like when when some of
the stuff dropped initially I would send
I'd send him an email and I'd say here's
my arguments against your position
um but I think they should treat you
with respect you're making a point you
should be treated with like the way he
shouldn't have just been sneered at or
yelled at they should have like they
should have they should he deserved to
be given a good
hearing a good counter argument yeah I
think what you get once you get to a
certain level kind of a popularity and
once you're in the social media sphere
in some sense you don't it becomes more
of like a a Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome
out there and not as much of uh probably
the grounds you guys are used to where
people communicate exactly and so the
thing is like when I would write them
that email uh he would say thank you
like he was appreciative or like you
know I'll be on his uh you know Channel
with him and he'll he'll you know he'll
criticize post-modernism and I'll say
well I think there's value to
post-modernism and here's the value and
here's like you know Foucault was saying
this and yeah you know and there that I
was saying uh and you know and he'll be
responsive and respect respectful yeah
right and so but but
the the the thing about that is is
like it's it
I want to maintain a good relationship
with like when he somehow he found out I
had diabetes and he sent me a like a
supportive email and I appreciate that
like I I I believe and this will get me
in hot water with some people but I
believe that Jordan is fundamentally a
good person and I think he has very good
intent and I think he's terrifically
talented
um but
um well the things that make you
adaptive make you prone to
self-deception and there's things that
he also uh we fundamentally don't agree
on yeah but but right
I think if people if we could get out of
the polarization around him and to be
fair I think he contributes to it I
don't he's I think by his own admission
he's not very good on Twitter yeah yeah
right no I think he would admit that but
I better think of what we talked about
when I was with when I chatted with him
if we could if we could get out of
polarizing and if he could get out of
being caught up in that
like what's really impressive is like
like when I've talked to him or John and
Jonathan and pajo and I talked to him
he'll get a lot of comments like do more
of those Jordan do more of those yeah
right because for me I feel like that's
the Jordan that I really respect and I
have affection for coming to the fore
and then there's this other aspect of
him that I I can't I I can't connect to
him yeah maybe he likes to get into the
fracus of it you know well see we there
that's a philosophical difference
between us I think trying to solve the
meaning crisis at the adversarial level
of propositional just ideas and
ideologies and that kind I don't think
it can be solved there we've been
talking about a much different level in
much different ways in which the meaning
crisis has to be solved I think I I'm I
I and I don't this isn't a this isn't a
scapegoat I did this costs me so this is
this doesn't come for free this isn't a
couple I'm meta political I think that
trying to get engaged with this problem
in a political framing is fundamentally
a modal confusion it is to make that
kind of profound mistake I think the
left at its best reminds us that we're
finite animals subject to fate and we
have to show compassion to each other
and the right at its best reminds us
that we're also called to Transcendence
and the cultivation of virtue and when
they worked where they were correcting
each other and helping each other emerge
and we're committed to democracy then we
have something wonderful when they break
that up into winner take all the other
side is evil and I have to destroy them
then that society that democracy is
doomed and over and I think that's where
our political situation is so I refuse
like Socrates I refuse and Plato I
refuse to participate in the political
yeah domain because for me I do not and
see Jordan wants to go in there guns
blazing and that's a fundamental
difference between us and so we've come
to understand that we won't talk about
those things right those are just ways
you guys are and I'm glad we probably
need people to be both ways I think I
think some of the online stuff gets like
um
it gets uh addictive probably you know
it is yeah I think once you get into
that world there's people that their
whole lives are that world you know and
he loves to argue points so I think if
you want to argue stuff yeah yeah you
can do it all day there yeah but it's
argument it's argument for uh Plato made
a distinction between Philo Sophia the
love of wisdom and Philo Nikia the love
of Victory and when it's the love of
Victory then you've lost the socratic
Spirit right right like I will disagree
with people Bishop Maximus and I we
disagree he's he is a committed and I
think profound and virtuous Christian
I'm not we know this and yet and but so
we disagree and profound and yet he's
one of my dearest friends and we draw
each other out and we contribute to each
other right you can disagree you can
argue you can challenge but you don't
have to pursue demonization destruction
you don't have to pursue confirmation
porn you don't have to pursue narrative
porn you know what the narrative of
narrative is I this is a real but I can
tell a story about that so I must mean I
know what's going on right and so we get
simplistic narratives we get
confirmation porn we get this we get
this sort of self this self-righteous
adversarial I'm gonna destroy the other
animal and see it shows how good and
it's ultimately narcissistic I I don't
want to participate in any of that crap
right right and and so you can see I'm
getting very animated that's okay it's
interesting I feel I feel I feel very
strongly that so sorry I I want to make
it clear that I'm not arguing against
Jordan in his absence he I would welcome
if he was here and could defend his
position yeah yeah I don't think that we
are I think I have a decent enough
relationship with and I'm sure you have
a great relationship with so it's like I
would understand if he wouldn't be upset
I don't know I don't think so I think he
I think he understands that we're like
yeah he he he's invited me to do things
like to uh he's putting together new
course Peterson Academy and I've had it
I've I've already done one course format
on intelligence rationality wisdom and
spirituality uh but when he when he came
to when he made the offer to me he said
well I said Jordan I'm not a
conservative I'm not a Christian and I
have ideas other than the United States
He said first of all you can criticize
me if you want you have complete
academic freedom and you don't have to
be a Christian and you don't have to tow
the conservative line I just want you to
come in and give the best possible
course you could give and I said okay
under those conditions I'll do it
because why wouldn't I that's a
completely virtuous context yeah and I
hate guilt by association well you're
associating with them
really that's become a huge problem in
politics overall in society you you you
can't do that you're right you you like
like it's so funny like people don't
even realize like the guilt by
association and then the little spouse
sort of Foucault and post-modernism who
are deeply influenced profoundly
influenced by Heidegger who was
literally Nazi right it's like what what
where does your guilt by how does your
guilt by association metric work right
it doesn't work consistently it doesn't
work coherently
um and you know I think that
it's important that we give people a
chance
to enter into genuine theologos with us
that we don't you know
part of understanding forgiveness which
is an important part of Agape that's
Jesus of Nazareth if forgiveness isn't
like Mercy I I let you off the hook
forgiveness is I'm giving you the chance
to enter into a relationship with me and
even given myself to enter in a chance
into relationship with you before it has
been earned
because something has happened that I
can't earn it until like I'm in a
catch-22 unless you give me the chance
to enter the relationship I can't do the
things that will allow me to re-earn
your trust right and so you need to give
me that right you need to forgive I'm
playing with the word a little bit right
you need to forgive and and make the so
that we're not bound in reciprocal
nearing so there's a chance for
reciprocal opening I think we've lost
we've lost the commitment to that we've
America used to I mean I'm a Canadian
and I only get it through the media
popular media but America used to be a
place at least it seemed to me where
people were initially given the benefit
of the doubt because you were all
Americans and you all believed in
democracy as far as I can tell now I
mean there's research to show this you
know Republicans are more afraid of
Democrats than they are of China and and
vice versa yeah right and nobody
believes in democracy anymore
everybody's convinced on both sides this
like I'm in this to win not to make
America better right and so I mean I I
have a great Point well you're an
American and I'm glad you're nodding to
that because I feel a little bit weird
here commenting no well I think that's a
great point I hadn't really thought
about that everybody's in it to win
they're not in it for how do we get out
of this how do we get to a better place
how can we all get to a place together
that we could not possibly get to on our
own that was The Proposal of democracy
yeah the proposal of democracy is we
will all engage in self-deception but we
it but if you have a different point of
view and I'm willing to enter into
genuine idea logos with you you can help
me correct mine and I can help you
correct yours and we can get to a place
together that we couldn't get to on our
own that is the great promise of
democracy it's also the great promise of
science John Dewey one of your great
philosophers said those two when they're
both working they work together
profoundly that's what America was well
at least to my mind yeah and did he do
the Dewey Decimal System yes that's that
John Dewey I knew it dude I knew he
freaking did it
God I can't believe some weirdo would do
that but I'm gratefully did it yeah me
too because I needed to get those books
um I don't know if you saw this John it
says the Moon is open for business
entrepreneurs are racing to make
billions that they're gonna basically
they're planning on opening the moon
where people can go there and have like
a little Colony hmm
that's that's
like as if the moon's gonna become the
new like
you know we're heading we're the
Mayflower you know yeah well I mean
that's I mean that's part of what's
happened
to the American Mythos right
is the the the the frontier the new
world the frontier when it's gone now I
mean there's nowhere left to go right
and and we try and Star Trek tried to
propose that space would be the final
frontier and we're still playing with
that but the problem is space isn't the
same way as another continent right
um and yeah I think uh uh uh America is
I hadn't thought about this sorry this
is just coming to me no it's okay it's
just the news it says uh with its
Artemis missions the U.S based agency
aims to lay the foundations for the
first human settlements Beyond her and
pave the way for extra planetary
colonization uh and that business is at
the core of its strategy
so I've wondered about this uh that
maybe there's a hunger in America for
another Frontier uh I didn't see that
yeah and maybe trying to make that
happen
I I yeah they
there's been some historians who talked
about that and how the frontier kept
moving until they hit sort of the
Pacific Ocean and then there was a
problem because this is over simplistic
but generally what happened is people
who were relatively more stable and were
more sociable stayed and people that
were a little bit Fringe would move to
the frontier and then they kept moving
and they kept moving and then they end
up in California kind of yeah Australia
right right yeah or Australia right and
then the problem is right we lost we we
lost that or the United States the
Canada didn't grow up that way but the
United States lost that ability it lost
that Vision yeah maybe that maybe maybe
there's even like a bit of a spiritual
Dimension uh to this there's a a try to
attempt to get a sense of uh well we
there's a frontier we can open up uh we
can Orient towards
I hadn't made that's interesting yeah
yeah well it just makes me wonder like
you know what if it's just a money thing
so that rich people could look cool and
take pictures on the moon
like what big vow I mean I guess you
could open up maybe a nice restaurant
there that only really rich people could
go to yeah I mean if it's just a
business thing and all we're doing is
sort of flinging phalluses into the sky
like we've been doing recently
um yeah that's just having that's just
modal confusion it's just trying like
trying to sort of have sex with the
universe yeah that's what it feels like
to me like a little bit of like a weird
kind of like let's inflict ourselves we
can afford it one of the Rockets even
looked like a penis it was really
embarrassing really somebody with
psychological training I'm looking at
this and going like that's a penis yeah
and you're thrusting it into the sky
right and it's like it's really weird uh
so yeah you're right it could become
that but you know if it becomes if it
becomes
Plymouth right if it comes if it becomes
a stepping stone to maybe opening up
colonization of other planets then that
could become something other I don't
know there it is right there blue origin
there you go see what I mean yeah that
thing
somebody just slanging a wiener out in
the space homie well it's it's you know
my pick my dick's bigger than yours kind
of yes yeah who doesn't want to just rip
their wiener off and just hum it into
the damn ether
you know
um
I remember at one point I hated my penis
for some reason really and I remember I
wanted to cut it off and mail it to
Africa to like a starving country and
they could use it for a food and that
crazy to think that
um well maybe but I mean a lot of people
get into
um a very ambivalent relationships to
their sexuality and to you know their
genitals
um has that happened over time you think
a lot of folks I think it's always I
think it's a perennial thing about human
beings I think human beings right
sex sex pulls Us in the two directions
sex pulls us
towards the animal
the finite we're having sex because
we're finite we're limited we're trying
to make more kids right but sex can also
call us and you you talked about this
there's a possibility of ecstasy there's
a possibility like and you have like
Tantra which is right people
understanding that
sex is a powerful way to reciprocally
open with another human being and if you
frame it the right way you can go into
ecstasy you can go into
self-transcendence you can you can you
can
touch aspects of your psyche that are
otherwise inaccessible and so
we've always understood I think that sex
is a powerful
thing and
it's it's it's got this tension in it
and one of the ways we try to just
alleviate that tension is just well I'm
just going to collapse to one side or
the other we'll we'll just right we'll
just do the one or we'll just do the
other and again it's it's Plato to my
mind like the toughest thing for me to
be
to do
loving wisely insofar as I have is to
hold those two together about my
sexuality right is to acknowledge the
animal part but don't identify with it
and to acknowledge the ecstatic part but
don't think I'm a God and identify with
it but try and keep the two talking to
each other
all the time
yeah I think I just gotten so
disappointed like I think because in my
20s I was looking at pornography a lot
you know yeah yeah choose that oh I
could see that yeah over going on a date
or something like because it was less uh
committal it was way less scary than
like possibly disappointing a woman or
possibly getting into a relationship
even like yeah like even if I had
appeased a woman and then things got
closer that was very scary and I
remember yeah at one point I was just so
sick of myself I was like I will just
just mail my penis and I guess I thought
Africa because it was like a starving
country or something they could use it
as like a soup meat or whatever but just
to put you in some August company you
know uh you know Saint Paul talked about
cutting off your left hand and Jesus did
too if it offends you right we can we
can misidentify with our body or parts
of our body in a way like you just
described and thank you for sharing that
that can really narrow us down
reciprocally bind us get us locked in
and we can feel trapped and we feel like
the only way I remember Eric promised to
destroy wow is to destroy right
um no yeah I I'm glad I'm glad you're
not there and I'm I'm really glad you're
you got out of that without having to
damage yourself yeah me too I think
there were just times where I was like
I'm in a home this thing over
the fence yeah you know just because you
just wanted to get rid of it it felt
like the cause of your oh I remember
saying something not quite as
self-mutilating as that but I remember
saying for the longest time if there was
a button I could push and it would turn
off my sexuality and leave everything
else in place I'd push that button oh
yeah I won't push that button now yeah I
won't push that button now it's
different and that's again the gift that
has been given to me by other people
especially my my my my this wonderful
woman that I'm with
um and so
yeah I I can understand that I can
understand how you can get to that place
but I think you know the rocket is also
just a projected version of that oh it's
like oh it's just trying to show off
yeah and it seems like rich people are
doing a lot of their own space
it's like everything has become very
privatized that's one thing that kind of
scares me you know yeah and then we're
losing we're losing the we we're losing
what can we do together and get to a
place that we could get on our own and
you know flinging the phallus into the
sky is a way of saying I can get there
on my own and the problem is I bet you
can but so what right the the price you
pay for that is you you haven't brought
everyone else along and then once you
get there You've Lost That capacity that
only civilization has yeah you're there
by yourself you're there by yourself and
and you and you lose all of all of what
all the often frustrating but also the
wonderful ways in which human beings
challenge us Beyond ourselves other
human beings yeah
yeah it's like even um
yeah it's like even like the Olympics
and stuff everybody's like it takes
different sides and points of views it
used to just be weak you cheered for
your team you know I wonder if it's like
that in other countries or if it's just
America doing all this well I
mean the problem was the the the
Olympics also I mean they they got
corrupted by politics right I mean it's
even back you know 36 Olympics and
they're in Berlin and Hitler's the right
the Nazis are running the Olympics oh
right and then you and then you got the
Olympics got corrupted by the Cold War
um right and they've always been pretty
fallible to uh somebody taking them out
like
yeah I mean whenever whenever there's an
arena in which Human Excellence could
come to the fore there are also people
who want to grab the shiny thing and
you with it and manipulate you
around it
um that's always that's always going to
be the case
um and that's a perennial problem and so
again the the answer to that is not
let's win that game
to my mind the answer is let's stop
playing that game together
[Music]
yeah it seems like that's a thing that's
really
been that's gotten rough in America is I
mean for one our news the faith in our
news dissolved yeah the Legacy Media has
no legitimacy and I mean it happened
like that I felt like maybe I'm wrong
but it felt like it happened well the K
the cable knew like you said a long time
ago the cable fragmented the networks
right and so when you don't have a
consensus out there when you don't have
a listening consensus that doesn't get
reflected back as a a consensus
authority figure when you're Walter
Cronkite and so many people are
listening to you they right and they're
all sharing that together a lot of trust
gets placed in You by a lot of people
when you're on some little cable thing
right then that 24 hours a day yeah yeah
yeah and then it it so you know CNN
change thing I remember when I was
watching CNN when it first came on and I
got like a shiver went through me I was
watching it and I realized
the journalists are interviewing each
other I grew up in journalism when the
journalists went to where the story was
and interviewed the people that the
story was happening to and I'm watching
CNN and it's they're talking to each
other and I go oh no this this is re
this is really bad this is good this is
gonna isolate itself more and more and
more and become more and more about
itself very very rapidly kind of thing
and it has I used to watch scene and I
thought it was like the place I would go
for news and then like I think five
years ago or something I just I was like
I don't this just isn't news anymore I
don't know but the news lost itself into
the conspiracy theories grew they feel
the vacuum because of course people are
trying to figure out the reality of news
they're trying to figure out real
information
so I guess people are searching for real
you know they're trying to figure it out
but what the conspirirtuality shows you
though at least I would argue this is
they're not just searching for
information for facts they're they're
searching for meaning they're searching
for belonging they're searching for
connection like Socrates they don't want
just empty truths they want
transformative truths and that's what
like if like like like
if you watch Like A Q Anon meeting
you know
yeah they'll be the conspiracy language
but it looks like a church service there
they have like there's songs and then
there's somebody gives like a sermon and
then they're supporting each other and
they're offering child care and it's
like and you like it's like like I'm not
condoning anything here but it's like as
a scientist I look at that and I go
you know they're they're creating a new
religion yeah because what people want
is they don't just want the facts right
they want the facts that connect them to
themselves to each other to the world
and to what's ultimate
in a lot of cultures are in a lot of
like you know America has become
extremely diverse you know you have a
lot of diversity issues like in France
right now like where Canada too yeah
yeah is it
is that just a phase that we go through
as places diversify like schools of
thought changing like are we eroding
sometimes or are we evolving do you feel
like that's where I sometimes wonder
like
you know is diversification is it too
soon in some of these places is it yeah
not is it right or is it wrong because
it's it is what it is you know
um but what is the byproducts of that
and because some of it seems to be kind
of scary in some spots you know
yeah I mean the the and it may be too
big of a fish to fry you know
well I mean calm Community common Unity
um the the problem we're facing is we've
uh I think for a good reason we've
decided we've we've realized that we've
marginalized groups of people unfairly
we've disenfranchised them they haven't
been included they have valuable things
to say uh
uh somebody I'm I'm recording some
episodes which uh Greg Thomas he's been
he's a he's a black man and he's been
teaching me how much Jazz and the blues
contributed to American culture to
American democracy it's been really that
series is going to come out eventually
this has been yeah we just went to
Graceland the other day so yeah and so
right and and he talks about being an
omni-american and being a radical
moderate or like and talking about uh a
cultural world view rather than a
racialized worldview
um and you know I I I applaud his
courage because you know it's difficult
to make these things and uh make these
kinds of statements but I I think what
he's putting his finger on is yet we we
have to do this thing we we have to stop
hurting people just because of who they
are and I firmly agree with that but we
haven't been we haven't member at the
Ecology of practices we haven't been
counterbalancing that with Okay good
let's do that but what we need to do is
we need to balance that with what are we
doing to strengthen Community this is
called complexification so let me let me
give you a biological example of this we
you and I started out as zygote a
fertilized egg initially the egg just
the cells just reproduce but you know
then they they start to do something
they start to differentiate they start
to become skin cells and lungs cells and
hearts oh wow right differentiation you
fight a little or not no well here's the
thing but that's the thing while they
are differentiating they are so
simultaneously literally self-organ
self-organizing they're also organizing
into organs and so the a living thing is
simultaneously differentiating and
integrating and when I am some look at
my hand my hand is very differentiated
but it's also integrated when it when
and when it does both of those it
complexifies it gets emergent abilities
emergent powers and if you only
integrate you get stultifying Stillness
and if you only diversify you get
frustrating fragmentation you need to
have them properly integrated right so
that you get complexification I think we
should be I'm not saying we should stop
pursuing
the diversification that we're doing
there are good moral Arguments for doing
this and there's even good cultural
arguments right but what we actually
should be pursuing is complexification
of our culture which means we should
also be countering balancing that with
yes but what binds us together and
simple liberal tolerance doesn't do it
it's not enough it's thin soup and we've
lost we've lost the Civic religions
we've lost the sacred religions we've
even lost a shared popular culture and
just being taught you know well let's
just all be nice that's not that that's
not realistic it's not enough it's not
enough you need a shared Vision again I
want everybody to hear what I'm saying
pursue the diversification this is I
hear it that's right but it also needs
to be counterbalanced with also pursue
the integration so that we complexify so
that we literally grow and have emergent
abilities to deal with the problems that
we're all all collectively sharing yeah
I think that's right I mean you know I'm
a my father's from Nicaragua but I'm
mostly viewed as just a white guy you
know
um but it's been like it definitely
feels like they've made just why a lot
of times immediate feels like I'm not
saying this is real right but it feels
like and I have friends that feel like
that the that like a white Christian men
are just made to be like the enemy you
know and that they've never done
anything good demonizing people will
will always end up it's been horrible
because there's so many good people that
now start to
say okay you want to make me the enemy
then that's what I'll be you it's almost
like not that's what I'll be but then
I'm gonna separate myself from this
Society because I'm not even respected
in it yeah does that make any sense yeah
it makes direct sense to me as a father
my son was in a program in which he he
would come home and he would feel
dejected because he was demonized that
way
and one point he said well you know what
and this is the effect this had on him
I'm going to join the right because at
least they'll work on my behalf and
they'll stop demonizing it and I had to
sit him down I said Son don't do that
like you're giving in to like you the
shadow side of what's happening to you
is coming out but I like I had empathy I
get like if you're demonizing somebody
do we really like do we really think
that oh you've made me feel really
horrible and guilty about myself for
like all a long time I I'm just gonna
join your cause no some people will do
that because they'll give in but a lot
of people are going to give that the
finger and they're gonna fight back yeah
because like like you you can't do that
with people so we again we've got to get
the balance how can we take
responsibility for what has happened
without just transferring the group that
we're going to hate right and and this
is a really tricky problem and and yeah
it's very complex it's it's very hard
hard and
um like I applaud people like Greg I'm
mostly on this issue I feel that I'm I I
don't have the requisite education or
expertise and I also feel that you know
I'm not the right person to so I'm
trying to really really
listen to people who I think do have the
proper place and role to try and wrestle
with this and learn from them as best I
can yeah
yeah well I think that's always a good
idea you know I mean it's just it's it's
just it's nice to think about and talk
about you know it's like it's just nice
to be able to share that thought and and
uh just have it be discussed or heard or
whatever you know and I think we should
I don't think I think I I think making
things uh topics that we can't discuss
that we need to discuss is really
problematizing things for a lot of
people their problems don't go away by
talking about them as if they don't
exist right yeah and you create you
create people that are have feet then
you give people into fear all right so I
I know an increasing number of people
who are I can see that
the fires of resentment are building in
them yeah and it's dangerous it's like
this is like what like the Weimar
Republic right the Versailles treaty
will crush the enemy into the dust
because they're demons
and you just you end up breeding a demon
that's ten times worse
um so I like I hope that we can get to a
place where we can do that we can do the
kind of thing that you and I are trying
to do here where we can do this like you
know the the this deal logos
conversation where we wrestle with
things
um and we do it honestly and and people
are allowed to make mistakes without
immediately being condemned like people
are so afraid to make a mistake you
can't learn if you can't make mistakes
like people have to be able to make
mistakes and say oh I'm sorry I didn't
realize like oh yeah maybe that was a
racist thing I didn't know right I
really honestly didn't know can you
accept that I didn't know and then can
you help me right but if we get to a
place where you can't make mistakes then
you can't learn and like it feels in a
lot of places people are walking on
eggshells and everybody's terrified
about making a mistake and then
everything gets this chilly superficial
kind of conversation and then and then
we can't solve any of these problems
well I think it's kind of where
Hollywood is kind of pigeonholed itself
with some of its uh adaptations and
they're paying the price yeah so they're
they're claiming that this is what
everybody believes and then the box
office is repeatedly telling them no
they don't and they resent it and
they're not listening well it's almost
like they have like stuff like they're
trying to create Stockholm syndrome with
uh with their audiences you know not the
not that they need to be one way or the
other but just that like can we have
some reality because what gets to be
scary is as a regular person you start
to question your own reality
you're like am I there's no way that I'm
insane suddenly you know what we should
go back
to make making great stories that are a
great myth that afford people being
imaginal yeah that call them to wisdom
and virtue and then within that ask them
to consider issues of race
and gender and economic status rather
than hitting people over the head with
condemning messages or very superficial
representation so that people watch this
and they say this is boring or I'm tired
of getting preached at like again
like and here's a here's it like right
here there's a point I want to make we
should be able to criticize the method
without automatically being a a told
that we are criticizing the goal I think
there's a go should we reduce racism and
racial tension should we make things
more fair between like the Sexes and the
genders yes
and because I really believe that I
think there are there are good and bad
ways of doing that and we should be able
to work together and I could be wrong
and you could be wrong and we should be
able to criticize the methods
if we actually believed in the goal if
we didn't believe if we actually believe
in the goal we actually believe in
helping the people we should be able to
criticize the methods like science does
in order right instead of right I'm no
actually I just want to plant my flag
right right right and so like it's
no it's a it's a great point we should
be able to criticize the methods without
saying we're criticizing the goal yes
and it's gotten to the point now where
you can't even raise your hand and ask a
question without being lambasted so much
in society or online that it gets uh
debilitating to to any real conversation
yeah and again I I would I would say
that I think I can honestly say that I
would say that equally to the left and
the right let me criticize the methods
and it doesn't mean I'm necessarily
criticizing the goal I agree with the
left your goals of making the world more
compassionate not making people the
victims of Fate the fate of race or the
face of the economic class yeah right
doing that right keep doing that but
also I I get they keep doing that over
and it's like come on I've heard this
story a million times well but but when
are people going to start to live a new
truth unless you start to tell them a
new story that's it the the it's like
that should never stop because that's a
perennial thing human beings are all but
you have to have the method that doesn't
dull people to it and I also want to say
this to the right you're supposed to be
calling people
to personal responsibility and virtue
are your leaders exemplars of virtue and
personal responsibility they don't seem
to be right yeah I agree with your goals
are your methods like you know how you
convince people to pursue virtue be as
virtuous as you can exemplify it be like
Socrates be like satara be like Jesus
right yeah so so I'm sorry I'm probably
pissing everybody off because I'm
criticizing both the left and the right
no I don't think look I think those are
challenges that everybody faces you know
and when your back's against the wall or
you feel like your back is against the
wall whoever that may be you're going to
uh
uh you're gonna retaliate more than you
are
um
like uh entertain if that makes sense
yeah it does you know so I think and a
lot of people are feeling that way it's
interesting how so many groups at the
same time can feel that way that's
what's kind of interesting to me they
can have opposite beliefs and be almost
exactly in their behavior and that is
like as a psychologist and cognitive
scientist I I like that is I'm sorry
this sounds arrogant I don't mean it to
be but it's so apparent to me it's like
you're both acting the exact same way
and both sides were like oh no we're not
all right they're yelling right now at
me but it's like you you you you you're
saying opposite I hear you saying and
shouting opposite things but you seem to
be acting in this almost the exact same
way uh and
um and so that for me is that's that's
that's a sign that like well that's a
sign that we're in trouble that's in a
sign that that like we we don't even
have debate we've lost theologos we've
even lost debate we've we've just got
like sort of verbal rugby or something
going on right right
yeah it is I think it really is you know
um I saw in some of your work you talk
about psychedelics and psychedelics yes
you know and the value of that in um
yeah like uh getting people to be able
to access and help solve issues that are
inside of them trauma yes yes right yes
yes have you had experience with it
I've done psychedelics in my past
um like a partier to learn
to learn so this was a long time ago
um I was about three or four years into
doing taichuan I was doing it
religiously at both sides of the world I
was doing it like hours every day I was
going to the dojo three or four times I
was getting all the you know where
you're hot like lava and cold like ice
and all those who experiences and
everything
um
and then something happened
that sort of
twigged me
um
so some people came to me I was in
graduate school and they said uh you've
changed what's different about you
you're much more balanced and flexible
and I realized all the Tai chias
changing me I'm so concentrated on all
the wonderful bizarre experience and I'm
not paying attention to how my character
my cognition my con like how I'm showing
up how how I'm you know comporting
myself to that was being changed other
people were noticing that night and and
that's that's been something I've been
looking for I keep looking for when when
somebody recommends a practice
does it transfer broadly deeply and
effectively into their many domains of
their life does it percolate between
different layers of their psyche
and so it's like oh oh oh and so
and I had a very good friend and I won't
out that person of course because of
course these things are still
technically illegal but that that's
going to change soon too
um
and they offer to uh do magic mushrooms
and I said to myself
and this is explicitly how I framed it
and I said I wanna
go on magic mushrooms and I want to do
tai chi Chuan hmm on
when I'm when I'm high because I want to
know what it's like what it what's the
what what it feels like with what the
phenomenology is like when because the
psychedelics reduce your egocentrism
right yeah and they and they open up
that connectedness you're falling in
love with reality I want to know what
it's like to do tai chi like that
because if I do what I can do is I can
remember it right and what I can and I
can use that like a touchstone and so
what I can do is right
I can practice and I'll have this deep
felt memory of what it was like and I
can keep calibrating the practice so
that I can get into that state without
having to use wow the drug and so that's
how I did it uh and was it helpful yes
yes it worked yeah that worked as a
strategy now that that brings me to
something like
okay
so remember the processes that make you
adaptive make yourself deceptive real
quick so it works as a strategy in a
sense it helps you get deeper and then
in subsequent experiences you was able
to still get deeper yeah because of that
I can get to that state now in touch one
without having to be on mushrooms dang
boy saving money
you know
well and other things yeah and other
things
um yeah I mean I can't I couldn't do it
now if I wanted to because of I have
been years in my left ear so many years
yeah it's a they don't know what causes
it but my inner ear can I can't talk
about it too long because it can trigger
an attack uh but you know what a
freaking crazy disease yeah it's a bad
disease
my inner ear will suddenly fill with
liquid and I'll get the worst vertigo
you can possibly imagine oh a buddy gets
out if you say his ex-wife's name around
him yeah yep that I can I can
start running in a circle
but psychedelics right psychedelics what
they do is
we and and we're not we're not uh you
know and I work with uh I talked to I
was uh Alex benier he's got his new book
out the bigger picture I was on when he
released it I I talked to people who do
psychedelic uh work
um
and you know and I've read people like
Robin Carhart Harris and others here the
idea is you when you're dreaming you're
basically doing what psychedelics do so
the idea is
your brain is always taking a sample of
information from the world and it's
trying to predict but like we've talked
about this right now you face two
problems in that
one is you can
call you can do what's called
overfitting to the data you can get all
locked into the patterns that are in the
sample but don't actually aren't in the
world okay right right does that make
sense yeah it makes sense that's called
overfitting to the data you can also
under fit to the data which is you don't
pick up on patterns that are that are in
the sample that are also that are
actually in the world so you there's two
kinds of Errors you can make the problem
you face is that they're in a trade-off
relationship as you try to solve one you
make the other worse and so you're
constantly caught between them and so
what you do machine learning like like
deep learning these machines that are Ai
and stuff yeah oh yes like yeah yeah so
they face this problem and what they
periodically do is they will throw noise
into the system they will shut off half
the nodes or they'll put in static
information and that what that does is
it prevents the system from overfitting
to the data it breaks up the frame
enough so that the machine will go to a
wider framing like we were talking about
earlier and it looks like that that's
what you're doing in dreaming
that's what psychedelics do so
psychedelics basically
get parts of the brain that normally
don't talk to each other to talk to each
other oh yeah right like the in-laws
dinner or whatever something like that
yeah and so
the thing is you they have to be put in
the right context because when you are
when you're sort of unmooring your
salience landscape right that could
possibly lead to Insight or you could
also rabbit hole and get into your own
personal really really
powerfully so you know back in the 60s
people talked about set and setting
that's still true you got to have set in
setting but you also have to have you
know a
two more s's one of the words is a multi
select it's sapiential that means having
to do with wisdom you need you need to
set if you're going to do psychedelics
you need to make sure you're doing lots
of other practices the challenge your
proclivity your proneness to
self-deception that's what I mean by a
sapiatrical context and then like how
indigenous people each need which they
do that they have the shamans usually
right and you also have to have it in a
sacred context right where there's a
context in which your Altered States Of
Consciousness are not just running
around free they have a world view that
can properly hone them and integrate
them in yeah I went to I did it on
ayahuasca ceremony right right man I
didn't
it helped me so much
it was unbelievable yes a cow and I'd
had I'd been sober for a few years and I
got and I'd done a ton of therapy but
I'd never been able to put I could I
couldn't adjust my perspective right I
couldn't adjust the framework that I was
looking at exactly and when it when it
helped me to the immense it did I feel
like it literally did a thousand
sessions of therapy in two days that's
what the research shows the research
shows unbelievable if put in the right
context and that's where we were in I
mean we were in a place they had a
shaman they had all these little light
uh like candles and all the others there
was a lot of music that really put you
in a special space yeah everybody was
wearing white gowns and robes were in
there there's a lot of symbolism yes yes
there was a ton of symbolism so use
there was a lot of like um traditional
like moments that we went through before
and throughout the experience it was
like a nine hour experience and and also
like a day there was this time where we
would get up with these Maracas or
shakas or whatever yeah chakras and we'd
have to shake like these little things
with the sand in them yeah yeah and
you'd have to shake them and do this
like dance ritual like there was a lot
of rituals yes that made it very made
the whole experience more powerful you
know and more transferable so you you
can integrate it you can transfer it
bleeds to different levels of your
psyche bleeds into different domains of
your life like I was talking right
that's exactly it the problem with that
now too though is that's becoming a
business well it's becoming a business
it's becoming commodified and you know a
an Ayahuasca tourism is oh yeah totally
yeah like come on down here you have
your experience so you can go back and
tell your friends about right kind of
thing and they're some of the flowers
even there's like a sexy woman on the
fire like what does this have to do with
you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like it just but yeah it's scary
that that's how everything becomes do
you think down the road we will look
back at Society like thousands of years
from now and like what a poor left turn
that Society took you think we'll be
back in like Villages and looking back
like what do you think it the long game
looks like if you have any predictions
well I don't know about predictions I
know about a possibility my good friend
Jordan Hall talks about a possibility
that we haven't had before
so until recently in order to get the
benefits of civilization we had to live
close to each other and then that gives
us all the noxious side effects but the
the force multiplication of civilization
was worth it right
but now what we can do is we can we can
do all the civilization stuff virtually
and then we could live in small-scale
communities uh because it's the civilian
project so we could live in you know
groups of 150 people growing our own
food we could live in this way that is
psychologically physiologically healthy
and yet we could still benefit from you
know that that massive Collective agency
that Collective wisdom the collective
intelligence that Civilization affords
and we could and now we did we don't
have to physically live like with right
right we could and so we now have the
possibility where we could turn to we
could live psychologically
physiologically physically as we evolved
to well participating in
a hyper technological civilization with
all of the force multiplication that
that gives you and it's this is a real
possibility and you know he's done stuff
to try and make it happen but you know
it's like a the uh you know the lone
voice crying in the wilderness kind of
thing until he isn't until he isn't and
I hope he keeps coming back to it
um that's a real possibility we could
take that turn it for me if we could
take that turn while building up uh you
know the these kinds of ecologies or
practices both individually and
collectively uh talking about
um and he and I've talked about how
those would integrate and support each
other
um that could you know that could that
could be a turn away from the some of
the the darkness that many of us feel
were entering into yeah
cool man I don't think I have anything
else to think about I mean I could
probably think about more but I don't
know if I could do it you know yeah yeah
yeah sometimes it's a lot to think you
know yeah yeah whenever you get burned
out from thinking what do you like to do
when I get burned out from thinking
um sometimes I like to do embodied stuff
like Tai Chi Chuan or meditate sometimes
I like to read some very good literature
uh where I'm putting myself sort of into
somebody else's uh thinking do you read
fiction ever yeah I'm reading uh I'm
reading the last of the wine which is a
really wonderful historical fiction
about Athens in the Peloponnesian War
and we're following these two characters
as they form a profound platonic
relationship but platonic actually means
also sexual at that time so yeah but but
um I'll do it but but they're
encountering
they meet Socrates is there oh wow so
for me it's like I get to meet Socrates
and like and hang around with them Plato
I just I was read to a chapter and I I
sort of stopped and I savored the moment
and I read it again and you know they're
in they're in they they go to the
gymnasium and aristocles is there and
he's a wrestler and that's actually
Plato's real name he's aristically is
Plato Plato means broad shoulders
because he was a wrestler that was his
nickname and I said to myself I just met
Plato that's cool dude the Delphi that
was like your WWF huh yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was uh
I I I I used to be a big fan of like
science fiction and occasionally there's
some good science fiction but now
um like maybe it's because I'm older
um I'm finding a historic really good
historical fiction to be a a friend of
mine
one of my most important friends
Christopher massapiato my co-author and
so much work uh he works for the ravaki
foundation he's also a recommended what
is it Hadrian's Memoirs I believe it's
called I got that book uh it's about
Hadrian writing to the young Marcus
Aurelius trying to uh educate him and
how to be a great stoic uh uh Emperor
and so I find that kind of literature
when it's not hackneyed when it's really
well researched and well written I find
that very inspiring it helps me to ask
aspire to be the kind of person I want
to be and I find that
um
it it I find because it's inspiring and
it's beautiful I find it very uh
healing and restorative hmm
I was just reading
um
this book I think it's called The
Library you look it up by this guy Matt
Hague h-a-i-g and it's about this lady
she thinks her life is like horrible
right so she wants to take her own life
but the second she does she like wakes
up in a library and every book on the
Shelf
is um the Midnight Library that's what
it's called and every book on the Shelf
is a different possibility of her life
as she made different choices and
there's a billion books it's an endless
library of course so she can take one
and open it and she'll be in that life
and it's really interesting because it's
like it it the author just kind of takes
you on the journey where no
every life you think oh if I just stayed
and done this thing but there's a
million other things that are different
about that life that's right that you
didn't realize oh when I get to this
life like my father had passed away
early or
um my partner had left me or I was
cheating on there's just uh it's just
pretty fascinating to see all the
different like the broader view instead
of just being like very specific like oh
if this one thing changes I would be
awesome but if that one thing changed
and so many things would change that
that's excellent I think I I think I
would like to read that book it's really
cool is it easy to read it blew my mind
how it was just what a creative idea it
was but it's a really good idea that's
what good literature can do right yeah
it can it can persuade you like it
without making an argument but
nevertheless it it rationally persuades
you to really consider and reflect on
things yeah it kind of made me excited
it was like I hadn't read something that
had like kind of a new idea and or
something that I'd never thought ever
heard seen before you know and I was
like oh this is exciting it felt
promising you know new ideas that have
both truth and relevance see like you
said they're so nourish yeah right they
feed your mind in a way that info
information you know doesn't uh yeah
we're at a place now where everyone has
access to the same information so the
the value of information
itself has kind of diminished unless you
can iterate that information or share
that information to people uh concisely
and effectively and in ways that they
can digest it I think that's one of the
reasons why people are going uh to a lot
of like orders and speakers and stoics
and yeah yeah
um yes different like uh just different
or what they'd be called but
evangelists maybe but that's but
non-Christian
non-religious evangelists yeah because
they they
need you know I don't know what I'm
saying I don't know I think what you're
saying is like people have a sense of
the you know of something that will open
them up in that way you were talking
about yeah and they see that possibility
and they're hungry for it yeah yeah
they're hungry for it and some of the
old mediums of it have
um proven to be non-valuable right
recently and so I think they're looking
for new mediums of it so yeah TSL it
said where's all the wisdom we've lost
in knowledge where's all the knowledge
we've lost in the information and so
yeah it's like that very much and and
good literature can take you back
I could take you from the information
into the knowledge and of its really
great literature from the knowledge back
into the wisdom John verviki thanks so
much man
uh thank you Theo there's this I really
enjoyed this I mean
um you you you you drew a lot out for me
and it was really wonderful you shared a
lot which was really wonderful and I
feel like one of my criteria of genuine
deal logo says we both got to a place we
couldn't have got to on our own it
wasn't just a dialogue we like there was
something a life
took shape between us and and grew for a
while and we sort of followed it I
really the Aesthetics and and the and
the meaning of that I find that very
very powerful thanks man yeah I think I
was afraid sometimes I get afraid to
talk to people that are or have a lot of
Education you know and and are good at
sharing information so I felt you know I
feel I guess pretty happy about myself
that uh you know I planned ahead and so
I had somewhat of a plan so that was
nice uh but I didn't feel like I had to
like stick to it too much and I felt
like I was able to like you know
communicate and learn and ask questions
that I think myself and my listeners are
curious about you know and be um just
like a voice for our little group of uh
of listeners so yeah man thanks so much
dude and
um yeah I gotta come check you I don't
want to come see a a a class or
something when I get up there to Toronto
you're welcome let me know yeah can
people come sit in there like they ride
along with a cop uh you there's uh you
can you can audit it because the
universities are publicly funded in
Canada you can audit any course you want
as long as it does as long as you get
permission of the instructor and it
doesn't violate the fire code sometimes
I'm in a room and we have there's it's
seating for 35 and there's 35 people oh
yeah right alone and I won't wear
nothing flammable either I won't wear
you think I'm gonna wear wool or
something I probably won't so but thank
you for letting me know John verakee
thank you so much for your time thank
you so much
[Music]
these leaves I must be
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life
[Music]
gonna take